yeehaw Bob Saget I I am actually excited
to be I'm excited to be anywhere but I'm
especially excited to be talking to you
I'm excited to be talking to you to
thank you and we tested you your clean
buddy
I am your free and clear virus I did I
usually have like Trump had someone take
his SAT I usually have someone take my
Cova test for me did Trump have someone
that true yeah it's true apparently but
I don't know which what's true right
what the hell is true well anything
before the internet is hard and even
during the internet it's hard because
they splice things up oh it's all sound
bites you could you could hate anybody
or love anybody I know it's you know
it's weird man is when the the deep fake
stuff like how long do we have before
you don't know what you're seeing do we
have before you know we see like a world
leader declaring war on us and we don't
know if it's real yeah correct how long
I say now somebody could do it right now
I mean I don't I don't know cuz North
Korea could could fire missile and it
wouldn't go anywhere I don't think I
like how they introduce new players like
now you have to be worried about the
sister right honest I like the evil
sister and she's thin yes and you
probably think she's mean she will be
she's gonna be very mad oh he'll be a
Karen a Karen imagine if your [ __ ]
kids named Karen what a bummer that must
be if you're a nice person named Karen
and then Kay well it's like Corona beer
I mean I can't believe they had to stop
that that that makes me sad I mean they
stop the name that's what I'm told they
stop making it now I don't know if
that's true that's the source I heard
nice they'll enjoy a Corona I'm not a
[ __ ] child
I like Corona Lite but what am I gonna
do and then and then AIDS candy that was
a smart move you had to stop that diet
candy yeah it makes you lose weight it's
ironic ly sad most people don't even
know what we're talking about is a yd s
right correct it's called a diet candy
like a chocolate yeah that you'e T I
never took it I mean it's like the X
lacks for dieting I was it like a Rolex
lacks actually helps you diet also but
all it does is just get rid of the food
that's in your body it's not healthy
no no I was somewhere once that I was on
a mo diem because I was having
rough day I don't know what happened
that's another diuretic right or
constipate er yeah I mean it's it's it
suppressant candy oh so it's an appetite
suppressant so it's not a knows X lakhs
xx makes you get relaxed it helps you
make [ __ ] diarrhea explosive explosively
if you know box you can shoot yourself
to death you can OD on it but it's barf
what is barf barf is urgent it says oh
that's funny Barbossa detergent is that
real they did discontinued it because
people vomit did they find out that
really did discontinued Corona beer that
sounds so weird
that's what I heard from somebody
classic there was also a candy called
anal warts that they decided to take off
the market
you know that's kind of [ __ ] that I see
why do I do it you never went there
couldn't help yourself all those years
of full house production of Corona beer
halted see and I don't understand why it
had to be cuz they're fools
they're just chicken [ __ ] nobody gives a
[ __ ] you it doesn't correlate to me no
it doesn't what it's not called Co vid
by the way right and corona corona
viruses occur every single year and now
we can't see those ads of cool-looking
people gorgeously shot at the beach with
the lime and the beers right there mark
Normand had a funny bit about that so
you put it on an Instagram but like it's
almost like they already knew cuz like
they're always someone alone yeah one
person in an ice bucket with four beers
or two people I think I don't think it
was because because the name Corona
thing is just because of the like
lockdown period when people couldn't be
at work bro somebody sent me something
about Mexico holy [ __ ] I had no idea
there that many deaths every day in
Mexico in Mexico yeah holy [ __ ] is crazy
this is a bad week for murder yeah this
is Mexico but all over the state - it's
been crazy in New York City well they
told cops that first of all cops are
trying to they're retiring left and
right in New York and then they told
them they can't
trained people by putting weight on them
they can't put an e on their back or
their neck or any other place and they
can't administer chokeholds and there's
all these jiu-jitsu guys who train cops
that are there like Henner Gracie put a
video on his Instagram page he works a
lot with cops Jamie Henner Gracie and
explaining was a terrible idea like you
can't control someone any other way
unless you use the violence unless you
hit them with things they used to be the
Oldham nut squeeze is that back in the
day well you could meet somebody yeah so
he's a warning to mayor de Blasio but de
Blasio is a fool man he's he's a foolish
person well we have to have order but we
also have to have peace well I don't
know how we are so we are so [ __ ] up
right now so [ __ ] up it got so far
gone in so many of these precincts and
so many of these these these look at
this one guy who literally does not know
how to grapple and this cop tries to
take him down and what do you think is
adrenalin and adderall and a person that
that is that I think the cop didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was doing this is the
thing these cops don't they they should
all be you know I'm Andrew yang said it
best he said every cop should be like a
purple belt in jujitsu he's right
everyone should know or judo or
something they should know yeah you're
right how to wrestle how to defend
themselves and a lot of cops don't know
anything they literally don't know how
to defend themselves so then they're
left with weapons that should also be a
psychological training oh yeah as well
they I understood I heard someone speak
I believe it was
who's our Carl Sagan he's Ross Tyson
lovely guy are you talking about uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson
yes thank ya sorry I didn't hear the
first part I'm going deaf slowly are you
I don't have Corona but the left ear is
out really no I took a day quo did you
ever play in a rock band or anything I
have really well III can beat I play a
guitar I play guitar
Stamos plays the drums yeah true you
guys get together we do we say he has a
band room we haven't done it in a while
because we can't right now they tested
well yeah yeah
to get mic love from the Beach Boys that
Cove it I don't know I love that you
gave me one I love that that you
personally but I love that I had one
just now well it's I think it's
important for everybody know because you
can get mine [ __ ] yourself and think you
have it
I've mine [ __ ] myself a bunch of times
like my short of breath yeah we've all
done it we do it at night it's a panic
attack
yeah and it could be just I get
allergies and I'm also had walking
pneumonia cuz when I'm up on the road
over the years you just are on planes or
international stuff and you go at your
heavy breathing and then I find out oh I
just did ten dates in a row then I come
back and my doctor says Bob you have
pneumonia yeah
so drunk right yeah and you don't know
what the [ __ ] is coming out of the vents
on the planes is I just being next to
people they're farting in your face too
literally well [ __ ] spray they freckle
you they walk by when they go to the
bathroom and people don't know what
freckling is I'm not telling you yeah
there's a product called freckled and
they're taking it off the market I
wonder if people are gonna go back to no
masks in public I think there's gonna be
a certain number of people they're just
gonna keep wearing masks I think you're
right and when I was in Japan I didn't
understand the mask theory which was but
not about I don't think it was about a
contagion type thing it was about
cleanliness it was about the air quality
I mean it's also about being polite the
Japanese culture if you have sniffles or
something like that you don't want to
give it to someone else yeah they're
more thoughtful and considerate now that
is what we're lacking here yeah the
people that are yelling I'm not wearing
a mask you've taken away my rights see
that lady in Florida yeah bars give me
100 free meals to the people that don't
wear masks yep Florida has the fourth
number of coronavirus cases on earth if
Florida was a country it would have the
fourth on earth yes well they opened it
up to prove their point that their petri
dish was impenetrable
well they open it up to Disney World
they did they opened Disney World
and people loved the idea of not waiting
in line so they're willing to die what
is a skinny video of Disney World
opening day there's a sauce going around
Saturday that there was some influencers
that went because there's a lot of
people that on YouTube that just go to
Disney parks all the time yeah yeah and
they were saying they felt sick and
I just went the next day and they're
like our this is fun but we all of our
throats hurt real bad
oh my god I think they all have it
unless they're faking there probably was
a lot of use in there Splash Mountain I
mean there's things that there's no way
droplets don't come out of you and go
into the mouths of the person but how do
you ever see the movie outbreak years
ago it just it happened yeah so there's
a mazing shot in the movie it's a point
of view of a phlegm ball and it's
literally follows phlegm a guy laughs
it's a comedy of course laughs of a
piece of phlegm comes out of his mouth
they follow point of view they do CGI
are beginnings of it and it goes into
another person's mouth and that's how in
a contagion way then they should
represented how this thing can travel
and I wear a mask
was funny when you had bill burr on here
who's a mutual friend people do not
understand that I was goading bill into
going on a rant I was [ __ ] with no
they don't wrote it out like I really
don't wear I have a mask in my [ __ ]
pocket me today no your yeah it's funny
cuz everything's out of context
everything's serious but that's that's
what I'm committee trying so hard cuz
I'm an I'm a newbie at this I'm on my
33rd episode you're on the Hebrew
calendar you're 5748 episodes you know
you you're 10 years of doing something
that revolutionized this okay so I just
started it because I bhisma for kovat I
started it because I was doing shows and
I'd be in a theater and people would be
yelling at each other and I would go
guys woody what are you doing or I'd
have a bit about prejudice when I was
six years old when there was profiling
when there was segregated bathrooms and
I started talking about it people would
get angry in the shin do you get me for
at the world one guy yelled the South
will rise again
well this is pre kovin pre covered the
guy yelled out the south will rise again
my response was sir we're in Boston here
I was at the wilberth he was serious he
was a hundred percent serious and then
they went and went to tag him and I said
no leave leaving be you know unless
someone continues I deal with it we both
will rise again isn't [ __ ] Boston but
they've had a long down
time and lost in 1865 you gonna rise
again the other thing is they're pulling
down statues right so the statues are
like uh they're like chocolate Easter
eggs Easter bunnies the ones that are
Hollow mm-hmm so if a statue to me is
less than an inch thick of the lining
around it and it's hollow inside right I
think it an inch it could maybe stay up
if it's heavy enough but if ten guys
could pull it down with a rope and it's
made of aluminum that's gotta come down
it's like a Jiffy Pop it really is
here's the thing about these statues
this is one thing that people need to
understand all the modern laughing about
it by the way because I'm trying to find
humor in what's so chaos it's chaos
obsessive history some of it should be
dismantled some of those tattoos should
go they really shouldn't be there but
they should greet him and bring them to
some sort of a Civil War Museum or
something like that but a lot of those
statues look there's Genghis Khan
museums right there's museum pieces on
Genghis Khan he killed ten percent of
the world's population while he was
alive there's something about those
statues though that a lot of people
don't realize like they were really
cheaply made and put up very quickly in
response to the civil rights movement
what people don't understand that those
those aren't like these long standing
homage is to these great generals no
there were in response to the civil
rights movement so they started putting
up these Confederate statues you know
that's why they're made they're made
like [ __ ] their meters quickly yeah you
can make them I thought that we could
high pans yeah but then you go to know
random foil you got to see grant to work
grant statue I mean it's made of molten
lava they probably want to take his
thing down too
this is the thing you know what take
everything the Trump said something and
everybody thought he was joking like
what's next they're gonna take down
Lincoln they're gonna take down George
Washington never it's like get the [ __ ]
out of here and then I'm gonna do that
but they are doing that they are trying
to take down George Washington statues
and people are saying you should get rid
of George Washington statues because
George Washington's slaves and George
Washington was a white supremacist and
he didn't want to own slaves he wanted
to abolish it from what I've read and
from what I understand it would be so
hard to know it would be so hard to know
other than what he wrote in and you know
unless you have a [ __ ] time machine
it would be so hard you're right we
don't even know what history is right
now Yeah right we're being fed I try to
watch all news things or none I try to
watch every single Channel because I
want to see where the world says well I
think that's the worst way to get news
is off television I think you get so
much nonsense and so much posturing and
virtue signaling and so much bias like
when I watch CNN I was watching CNN when
they were correcting Trump on these
these things that he says it wasn't even
news it was like this weird an opinion
piece that was a tabloid it's a dog but
Fox is tabloid a tall man in this NBC
some there's jewels in all of it though
there's reality in all of it because
you'll get just the right
broadcaster an actual broadcaster and
news journalist you'll get a couple of
people that are that on every one of
those networks yeah and then you'll get
a guest that feeds the beast rather it's
become like South Park and it's gonna be
offensive to some people what I'm gonna
say it'll be like we have here the
president of United States and it's a
split screen and also a [ __ ] you know
and then they'll have just because
everyone has a voice and and that's an
offensive word by the way
[ __ ] President of the United States No
rimshot please don't hit the button but
but that's what they would do or our man
in a hoop skirt you know they would do
that on South Park constantly and we've
kind of become that here's a person that
has you know ten million people looking
at them on whatever site you look at and
then someone who has 5,000 people who
has a YouTube page that people go to but
it's just to start everybody goes to the
news source they want that validates
what their opinion or to get angry mic
tune into Fox News just to get angry or
tune in to CNN and get angry if you're
on the other side it's it's weird time
man but it's got to come together I know
that's what you try to do that and I
know that that's what I mean stand up is
the root of that
in a way yeah because you can make fun
of ideas that maybe even someone agrees
with the idea but if you mock that idea
and it's so funny it gets them to laugh
they have to think about it you know if
you like say if you're how beautiful is
that so to be able to do that bad do you
want to do it right now oh yeah I'd love
to do it right now I need to do it I had
this bit about Trump and I had this guy
come up to me he goes I'll tell you why
that jokes good he goes I [ __ ] love
Trump and that joke was hilarious like
when you can say when you can make fun
of something that someone loves and they
still think it's funny right yeah then
they have to think there's a skill to
that I try to do that I try to it's
impossible to come up with something
that pleases every side and every
perspective but I'm trying but that's
why I end up talking about my dick so
much because it does it does lean left
and it's a pleaser I might have to say
that again sometime it's a pleaser you
should sell t-shirts on your website
that's it please you just got me some
merch ideas it's a good merch idea right
there yeah it's it's impossible to make
everybody happy you cuz here's one thing
everybody doesn't want to be happy
there's a lot of people that they love
being miserable they like being angry
it's easier to be angry yeah than it is
to dig out and wake up positive and go
I'm gonna try to write some things today
yeah that's right I mean ri ght make
things better in the world by putting
out my energy by trying to if there
could just be a [ __ ] discourse yeah
it's just there's also with people that
don't agree there's also a problem that
we have timelines like we have a
deadline we have a deadline our
deadlines November or the world's gonna
fall apart we got to get rid of this
[ __ ] by November and everybody's
clamoring and trying to figure out how
to do it and pretending Joe Brydon brain
isn't melting and everyone's running
around trying to put together some sort
of with actually they got a mic stand
duct tape and a pipe cleaner he's gonna
be fine he's gonna be they're gonna
weekend at Bernie's him all the way to
the [ __ ] cabinet he's been doing some
goods putting out some stuff that's
pretty Dave we're go online he's been
given Sweeting know do some videos
speeches
things that are a little bit more
promising than gem of the other deep
fakes is there a guy who does a good
Biden impression I have not heard a good
Biden if we were doing stand-up there
would be a guy who would have there'd be
some comic I would think Dana Carvey
would be able to do it
he's such amazing have you had him here
no I'd love to
oh he and I love him so much yeah he is
one of the purest sweetest people I've
ever known
he was the his character of Lorne
Michaels was the original doctor yes
right yes Mike Myers sort of like Myers
when they hung out and they would always
be the pinky in the mouth and yeah yeah
it was it was Dana is an original Dan
he's brilliant yeah he's brilliant he's
we would sit around back in when you
were I think you were six but we would
go to fabs this Italian restaurant on
Van Nuys and we would be with our wives
Hobbs fabs he stayed with his wife my
wife and I got divorced but I have a new
wife she was congratulations thank you
Jesus van nuys used to be a hot spot I
was looking at this video oh yes
there's a thing with the LA Times had a
photographic essay of Van Nuys Boulevard
in the 70s and it was amazing it was all
these people with bell-bottoms and these
cool cars and they used to on Saturday
nights drive their cars up and down the
road it was like fun yeah but it was
like a place where people would go to
cruise yeah it was boogie nights without
the heroin and and people getting harmed
giant prosthetic market marky-mark
prosthetic dicks so so we would sit
there and it was right before he got
Sarah Night Live what year is this 586
it was one year before he got that and
before I I had been in a Richard Pryor
movie that was the first thing of
consequence and then what movie was that
critical condition you got to work with
Pryor I got to spend a month with him
and I got to hang out with him because I
was one of the hosts at the store for
eight years and you got to work with
prior when Pryor was prior what was
after the fire but it was a hundred
percent strip without real fire it was
after the fire did Jo Jo dancer
and and critical condition was directed
by Michael Apted a great director who
did coal miners daughter made a lot of
important moves did the 7up series do
you ever see that 7up 14 up 21 up took
seven people through their lives from
London and followed them every seven
years to the documentary about them oh
wow just a real special brilliant lovely
man
it was head of the Academy for a while
anyway so what happened was but but but
working with Pryor we were you know when
you're doing a movie we were in a shower
stall in an old hospital and it's
supposed to be Rikers Island or whatever
the hell that prison is up there is that
desert Rikers which one in New York
what's the UM I think that's Rikers
right yeah I think that's what it was it
was representing them but we shot it in
High Point North Carolina with really
good actors Joe Montana and Ruben blades
and all these Randall Tex Cobb some
really cool [ __ ] who weird eclectic
group and i swatched him the other day
in Raising Arizona he's a great actor
that's great man he's a that will move
his while that's one of the bets that
low point of view shot in the
supermarket image images in that in a
lot of Coen Brothers movies they're the
best [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love brother worki Big Lebowski is my
wife every day it's like let's just
watch The Big Lebowski you know it's a
dude floating in space man sorry I was
interrupting you so yeah I can well
that's what I do is prior so we're in a
shower stall and and we became friends
and we would go to dinner I would I was
the guy I'm I'm always wanting to make
things better somehow I was raised that
way by my dad and my mom to try to make
peace for people that's the thing and
and he liked that I would invite him
because people didn't invite him to [ __ ]
cuz he was kind of unapproachable to
some people so we would go to dinner and
we would laugh and I would make him
laugh we we had to do one scene 40 takes
because one shot there was a long
Steadicam shot we had a dead body and it
was covered in water and I was supposed
to say something like the guy was in the
drink we found it but it was such a fake
looking body and every time I said the
serious line I was this young dr.
Richard just cracked up and so he's
looking in my face and there's no bigger
honor you look at you baby face
[ __ ] [ __ ] how old were you then
26 27 and Wow
that was a good scene that's Ruben Wow
I remember all of this really that he
and I so he couldn't the fact that he
couldn't look in my face and kept
laughing and it was a serious scene do
you know what an honor that is to the
guy that was an idol so I'm sitting in a
shower with him and he takes shows me
this thing this is graphic he shows me
the scrubbing brush and one side soft
knee that says just bristles and he says
I don't think he'd mind me telling you
this I always think about when you talk
about someone that you love that's
deceased would they be okay with what
you're saying so it's not TMZ garbage so
he would take the the hard scrubbing
part and he said this is what this is
what they took my skin off with mm-hmm
after the fire they had to scrub my
whole body but this [ __ ] and I've just
sat there and I remember crying I think
there was a combined empathy and then I
told him of like my sister that died and
then he was telling me you know you just
get close with people and then one night
I didn't invite him to dinner cuz he'd
had a hard day and he was mad at me the
next day and I was like oh my god so he
was enjoying so I said but he but he was
he was in a rough place he was you know
yes not he was complicated human but I
remember saying because when you're
acting you just down I was green I said
so you're upset with me I'm so sorry
this means we're friends right
cuz I upset you right and many went we
went to dinner again cuz cuz that's like
he's the classic complicated comedian
right yes with the hardest [ __ ] drug
addiction all the chaos growing up and
uh yeah everything work yeah I grew up
for awful yeah I mean that's his
headshot on the wall over there yeah
yeah I mean he was I think he was 19 and
was doing the button-down Bill Cosby way
of doing stand-up yeah but it's still
when you look at everybody goes over he
went and flipped like George Carlin and
all of a sudden he was a different guy
it was still the same guy you still saw
even though Cosby I know it was mad at
him cuz he thought he was lifting some
of his stuff or because we would get mad
at a lot of people but he's doing fine
now well I think everybody starts out in
imitation of the people they really love
and respect who did you start out
Richard Jeni a lot yeah he and yeah I
remember on stage once I caught myself a
year in the comedy I was like Jesus
Christ like I'm I'm aping his mannerisms
like it was but I don't see that one rid
of it I realized that you know you
become who you are but in the beginning
you know I think it's normal I mean it
happens with bands you know look Stevie
Ray Vaughan was deeply influenced by
Jimi Hendrix it's like yeah and then he
became Stevie Ray Vaughn even when he
does voodoo chart like if you listen to
Stevie Ray Vaughan's cover a voodoo
child it's Stevie Ray Vaughan it's still
it's voodoo child but it's Stevie Ray
Vaughan's version he became his own man
and I think all of us in the beginning
got into comedy because we wanted to be
some comedian that we really admired and
when I was just starting out I got a
chance to see Richard Jeni a few times
and I remember being baffled by his
ability to turn over material it was
stunning knew it so prolific so you're
gonna make me cry because I was close
with him as close as you could get
because he had such mental health issues
I didn't believe he died and I Dave
Coulier instant messaged me that's how I
not how you want to find that out so I
called his number and his girlfriend the
next morning and his girlfriend answered
and just said it's true Bob and I went
oh [ __ ] cuz I didn't believe it I
couldn't believe it I met him a few
times I saw him live of
a few times in the early days and then
once you know this was like when I was
an open mic er you know I went to see
him live at catch a rising star in
Cambridge when I was just starting out
and I sat in the front row and he made
fun of me it was great because I had
seen him on The Tonight Show that the
first time I'd ever seen he was on The
Tonight Show and he did a bunch of
appearances on The Tonight Show and then
I've seen one of his TV specials one of
his hour specials and then I got a
chance to see him several times and I've
told the story forgive me if you heard
it on the podcast folks but uh we were
at Eastside comedy club and he had just
been there and the host was just he I
got there like Saturday night after The
Late Show and the host was like he did
four different hours he did two
different hours Friday night and two
different hour Saturday night and
murdered and they were like Jesus Christ
and this was me I was like three years
in a comedy and I remember thinking god
damn that is so that was so impossible
to even imagine yeah that someone could
be that good then I got this chance to
see him a year later at the Comedy Works
in Montreal as a part of the festival
the Just for Laughs festival he was in
that little you remember you ever worked
that place Jimbo's plays no no no I just
did I did a show that the plasters are
for some broadcasted show that I hosted
Jimbo the guy who owned the club in
Montreal had this little tiny club that
was upstairs he away tomorrow met Aires
yeah yeah yeah I did it the night before
I was there yeah I was there that's
where you go yeah the night before
anything I did it with Jim Norton yeah
and I did it with Norton yeah and Brewer
yes I did it with brewer - yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was funny [ __ ] I was going
what the [ __ ] am i doing always you
can't always play gigantic but you're
taking over the world
you know I like little places too man
though I love it you play spaceships now
I play big places but I still I admire
the [ __ ] matter what you do by the way I
think you have to tell you that because
you know there's like five people Kevin
Hart thinks he's two of them that can
but you know comedy rock star [ __ ] yeah
I subscribe you know
wellhe's and and you're doing it and to
be on a thing with chappal and to be
able to do that and to be able to go out
there especially where we're at right
now and this is not I'm not there's no
nothing on my nose right now I'm just
telling you the truth from my heart it's
I do this I've always done it but more
so now I'm 64 years old now even though
I look you know 63 but you're what
you're able to do if you can unify
people in a room and we're in a drive-in
or at these giant places that you're
doing it is absolutely beautiful and
especially now whenever you're able to
do those dates that are coming up people
will never forget it when we come out of
this that's very nice I don't know if
we're gonna be able to I've kind of
resigned myself to I think we will I'm
fine
listen like legitimately I'm fine
working in comedy clubs for the rest of
my life I don't give a [ __ ] I just like
doing stand-up and that's one of the
things that I've gotten out of this you
know I've been doing the last few years
I've been doing arenas and they're great
but so is the are at The Comedy Store
yep that's great too I'm fine with that
I don't I honestly I just like to in
stand-up if we can never do arenas again
if no one ever no rock bands no UFC
every dozen arena again no football
games are ever in a sold-out arena okay
oh you can't do you have seen in the o.r
well they're doing UFC with no crowd
that's true and it's amazing I love it
I've called - yeah - fights now with no
audience and it's guy I enjoy it man
it's great I stopped just happy that the
fights are happening and like when I did
I did shows in Houston a couple of weeks
ago yeah I was talking to wanted to talk
to you about that yeah the Tony
Hinchcliffe and Brian Moses we we did
the Houston improv we had a great time
first of all it's a great room it's a
great room I supposed to go there I had
to Edna not because of what's going on
now yeah but you went in I was like wow
bro raise [ __ ] we wanted to we
just wanted to
you know first of all I missed I missed
doing shows but I miss hanging out with
comics on the road it's fun you know and
my buddy Mike Young I we always sure
we're together and it's like with my
brother yes it's fun you you know and
that's that's the big things like
touring on the road people you love it's
the best cuz like Moses is the best I
love him and I don't know I love Tony he
hosts Russ battle oh I know he's great
my best friends so it's like to be with
these guys we were just from the moment
we saw each other we'd go to restaurants
we do shows it was all smiles and laughs
holy [ __ ] we're doing stand-up again
this is crazy
Moses had done the weekend before he did
I forget oh he did American comedy
company in San Diego he did that place
which is apparently was open and now
they're closed again they closed La
Jolla again - they were doing the
holiest door sorry to hear that well you
know they gotta take precautions listen
man I was pretty nonchalant about it in
terms of like not worried but as more
time has gone on in terms of like
getting sick my fear is getting somebody
else sick that's not number one well
that's that's the key that's gay that's
what's [ __ ] lacking and that's what's
lacking from our administration that
there's empathy we need empathy well we
were talking about that earlier we were
talking about Mary Trump's book I read
some passages out of it today I'm ready
the whole book but I write I read this
long piece on it about what she chose
with him as a kid when she was young I
don't know but it's his niece her
brother was his or her father rather was
his brother and you kind of understand I
mean if she's being honest and I'm suit
assume she has first of all it's very
well-written
she's obviously extremely intelligent
like very eloquent like the way she's
writing it and and I believe she has a
background in psychology and the way she
writes it it doesn't it's not like a
hateful thing like she's basically
explaining why he's so [ __ ] up and why
he lacks empathy and what she said was
that the father was like a sociopath and
the mother was
ever around and was absent and it didn't
give him any love or attention and only
you and according to her use the
children to comfort herself instead of
being there for them and that he
developed this narcissistic
self-centered personality in response to
that and that his father would you know
would anytime he showed emotions or
anytime he showed me his father would
cast that aside and squash that inside
of him that's very clear yeah so he
developed this that's the thing that's
most disturbing about him when I talk to
people that are fans of Trump and they
say why aren't you like what do you
least like I go what I lease first of
all I don't understand the economy so
when people say he's good for the
economy he's good for business is that
short term what does that mean like that
that was pre kovat yeah that that's all
that it was the world's [ __ ] economic
over he is not the president for where
we're at right but the thing that
bothers he couldn't just if he would but
he's not capable the the problem is the
lack of empathy like when he would make
like when he talked about John McCain he
said I like soldiers that don't get
captured remember that is a crazy thing
to say to it well he's a war hero it's
funny you know I'm laughing at it
because of the it's ludicrous and
ludicrous
yeah I mean I'm not laughing well no I
mean it's horrific this guy I
unfortunately will be the first person
to laugh at the worst gallows of course
you're coming right and then it'll get
misquoted and then I'm a [ __ ] right
and you've been misquoted lately
terrible there's no way around that
no especially in this day and age when
they could redefine you with something
out of context but the point is that
what what they're what it shows there's
the lack of empathy is the last thing we
need right now well we need empathy we
need someone who can say something that
calms people down and brings us together
and inspires us man
people need inspiration and we need to
know and understand that we are all in
this together and we can go forth and
pretend we're not and keep burning
buildings and keep going crazy and
screaming in the streets for the heads
of politicians and kill the cops and all
that crazy [ __ ] or
or take your mask off that's my [ __ ]
right and [ __ ] you he never he wants
love that's the crazy part he wants to
be loved he thinks he's Don Rickles he
wants to when he puts people down and
say punch him in the mouth and stuff he
he's trying to be that guy I've known
people like him who would just [ __ ]
but John Rickles wasn't an [ __ ] it
was like a dad to me he was a lovely guy
that's why it worked when he would [ __ ]
on you it's like when guys don't it's
like the Pope right exactly like you
know when guys some guys can [ __ ] on you
and it's look that's the beauty of roast
battle and Moses's show the beauty of
roast battle is these people are
[ __ ] on the most embarrassing
aspects of each other and they're both
laughing at it and it's great and that's
what Jeff Ross that's his whole EEGs
area is I only roast the ones I love yes
which comes from the old fryers and old
masters before that and that's Ross's
thing he loves those he Buddy Hackett
and all that in New York he would you
like I'm going to the Friars Club you
want to come what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you you're gonna hang out with a bunch
of old dead men like that's how I
learned how much fun did you have I
didn't go oh but he was he was always
that guy you really didn't would it be
wanna be with a bunch of old dead man
listen man I back then in particular I
was crazy like this is what were you
doing for 2500 just I just stopped
fighting I was I was just not no longer
competing so I was still I still had
like this maniacal mindset I was a crazy
person you know I just wanted to play
pool and go stay up all night and were
you single yes I didn't wanna hang out a
bunch of old dudes right old dudes and
listen to some old jokes and listen them
talk about the Jackie Gleason show like
no no gotta go bro the only thing I had
one fun experience that Jeff took me
there for lunch
I go there this is maybe 15 years ago I
think I was there because I was doing
the Jack Black roast which was at the
Hilton I was the host I was the whatever
you call it the emcee the roast master
yes there were and and so Jack was being
roasted it's for charity
and so I go there and I hadn't been in
the Friars and
sit there and and I'm just sitting with
Jeff and I get the phone there's a phone
next to me and the phone rings they go
mr. Saget the phones for you and I pick
it up and the a man goes look to your
left and I look to my left and it's an
old Jewish guy with orange hair and he
goes [ __ ] you what I don't know looks
like red buttons I don't know and I go
what do I know you
he goes [ __ ] you welcome to the Friars
and he hung up that to me was kind of
cool I now it's probably a kovat petri
dish now I don't think so those guys
don't make it I think it's gone yeah I
think the Friars Club is gone yeah I
would have loved that now as a person
who like appreciates the history of
comedy I kind of wish I went to one of
those things just to see what it was
like to hang out with those guys I got
to me Red Skelton once that was pretty
cool that's really nice that was that an
NBC event back when I was I think I was
on fear factor
mmm but it was it was cool to meet him
did you enjoy that character yeah I
enjoyed the money that's all I enjoyed
the people I worked with they're fun
people what year was that when did you
start 2001 to 2006 I enjoyed I enjoyed
some of it I enjoyed like when nice
people won I enjoyed I enjoyed like
helping people overcome like this a
situation where they're really nervous
and I could coach them and talk them
through because it brought me back like
I used to I used to teach martial arts
and I coach a lot of kids in particular
I bring them to tournaments and I would
I would train them and then you know
like these 14 15 year old kids I take
them to tournaments and they'd be
[ __ ] panicking and I would talk them
through it and I would say you're gonna
get through this and you're gonna be a
better person because you got through
this because it's so scary when you get
through something so scary you become
stronger and this is something you just
have to go through and if you just shy
away from this
you'll shy away from this your whole
life but you can get through this other
people have done it and you can do it
too and I took a lot of that over to
Fear Factor and that's what I what I
loved is those moments where you would
see someone overcome and then they would
be so happy
and I'd be so happy to like ride a bunch
of times appear that's why you're so
good on it I was doing the video show
and there were things I was like well
this is my personality and other times I
go ok these are people are flying in
they're being flown in to LA they made a
video of their kid reciting all the
presidents when he was 2 right they're
all there and then I go and what are you
gonna do with the $10,000 and the father
says I'm gonna make a down payment on
our first house I'm the guys like 50
years old and I'm like I'm glad I got
this job right yeah that that's when I
go was worth to see all those people get
hit in the nuts for never yeah it's like
there's there's moments on in these
competition shows where you really do
feel like you feel like the world got a
little lighter like people got elevated
when you see someone win let me see
people win things me see people I love
watching people do better I love
watching them overcome I love watching
them like go through some difficult
thing and figure it out and get through
it and that the feeling of relief and of
just watching the adulation and
everybody's cheering and they're like
yeah surprise and yet the producers know
they've got something special but will
it deliver Howie Mandel's a dear friend
forever and he's on America's Got Talent
so here's a show that I always was
against competition shows I wouldn't go
on Star Search when I was broke I just
didn't believe in comedians competing
against things you know and then did you
ever go on any of those competition
things no no I didn't so I'm watching
America's Got Talent and they have a
handicapped person come out who sings
just like you've never heard anyone sing
so good and then you see the true joy in
the people it's not just showbiz
[ __ ] selling something and that's
that feeling that's that you came from
something that you never it's a dream
fulfilled and it's about the human
spirit the human spirit yeah that's real
I mean some people it's so fun to be
cynical for some people on the [ __ ] on
that but some of my favorite students I
used to be more cynical in
it's easy to be especially as a comic
when you're struggling and you're making
your way through the let you you know we
we joke about the worst things where you
know a lot of us are bitter
I'll give us our gel I'm not bitter but
I do joke about things I can't I can't
do it I know I need two minutes to tee
up some horrible joke and then three
minutes to get the [ __ ] out of what I
just did and that's gonna continue
because I can't not say stuff it is a
part of being a person who's a stand-up
comedian that you know that there's a
thing you're not supposed to say and
you're gonna say it and if you do say
you know I'm gonna laugh and you're
gonna say it and I'm gonna laugh we're
gonna go you [ __ ]
because when do I have asked us of many
comedian friends and people when do you
think I mean is it is it the teenager in
us is it that guy that's being told
don't do this is it or did you lock in
at 16 do you feel I kind of feel
sometimes I locked in at nine because
that was the world hadn't fallen apart
for me I didn't see what [ __ ] how [ __ ]
up everything was I mean you could go
deep psychologically with it but I think
at the end of the day we enjoy first of
all when comedians are around comedians
is when that shit's the worst right
that's when the most gallows humor I try
to out worst everybody and that time it
for you
though the thing that's out of context
in quotes that's when you're going to
get the most in trouble okay don't they
it's there it's gonna for a non-comic to
understand some of the horrible [ __ ]
we'll say at Canter's deli at two
o'clock in the morning though it's fun
and be laughing like dying falling under
the table and all we're trying to do is
make each other laugh it's not more
horrible mean people secretly hoping
everybody gets cancer that's not what
we're doing we're just we're saying
inappropriate things cuz it's fun to do
because I know you're a good guy and I
know you don't mean it that's the only
way it works it's letting air out of the
pressure cooker
yes it's stating that's why people go
how could you do that it's too soon you
don't do that joke sometimes you don't
do that joke I mean we know Brian
Holtzman vaguely yes Brian Holtzman is a
legend for doing material way too soon
that only makes comics laugh but he'll
do it on stage I remember
Susan Smith she's a lady who drowned her
children yeah and at first she said
someone stole the car or something down
then it turned out Bryan Holtzman's on
stage the week that happens and he goes
I heard those were bad kids he goes I
heard they said that close to the TV
they never put away their blocks they
spilt their milk those kids will not be
missed and people like oh my god it's
the hole they had it coming think that
we were [ __ ] crying we couldn't
believe and you know people would say oh
these horrible comedians they love this
shock and they're just mean and they
just want mean comedy it's not even that
it's hard to explain to a person that's
outside of the business but to me like
like if I'm around
Jeff Ross and something like that
happens I expect that he's gonna turn to
me and say something [ __ ] enough to
be the first person to say and I go Jeff
no but I'm saying no with love yes of
course of course enison I actually I'm
gonna date myself I don't have to now
cuz I'm married that's the kind of jokes
I shouldn't you know that's the ones I
but I know as I'm saying them but I
still say no but it's a dad joke thing
yeah bill burr said to me he was a guest
on my my my nubile podcast and bill said
to me you know what your act is Saget
said your act is all the lines you
couldn't say on Full House and you just
say [ __ ] all around it that's what your
act is I know it what what do you say
and then he pummeled me for twenty
minutes and I [ __ ] loved it and then
I attacked him for like ten minutes
but he is he's one of the best people
he's one of my favorite people he's one
of my favorite people on earth he went
to my wedding wind him up oh [ __ ] I was
I was I had nine stories to start but
that's why this is I'm so happy to be
doing this thank you my pleasure thank
you I haven't talked to anybody know
you've been stuck right well I had to
zoom last night night before with Norman
Lear and a bunch of musician friends oh
wow and we talked about the world you
let me talk about what the [ __ ] are we
gonna do and and it's just interesting
it's it's and we used to we would do it
in person we'd all sing songs for four
or five hours into the night and
and friends show up Stamos came John
Mayer came Dave Koz always comes to it
and it'd be music you play right no I
thought you were a musician now if zero
musical talent but you love I love music
love it
yeah the one's one of the things I love
about music is I don't know how to do
anything just enjoy it you should start
a band though yeah yeah just get think
three people that can't play no I'm bit
too busy but I do I do love music I love
it one of the one of the things I love
about is the fact that I have no skin in
the game you know it's like I love
comedy but I do it you know so when I
see someone make a great bit part of me
is like god I wish I wrote that right I
get I mean I don't get jealous but I go
like [ __ ] yeah or I'll see it and go
wait I did that 20 years ago well
there's always that right there's always
parallel thinking but the other thing
that gets me is like if I see someone
really kill I want to go home and right
it's like I can inspire to create Gary's
music just makes me happy like if I like
I've had like my friends honey honey
come in here and playing Carrie Clark
juniors been in here and well Everlast
is played in here like I'm a bunch of
people play music in here and there's
there's something about watching someone
do something that you have zero talent
in it's really special I think comics
really do we want to be a musician we
worship music be some yeah
some I mean I yes not all of them
obviously yeah I never had any desire to
be a musician at all zero no bird plays
the drums he's done of a [ __ ] well I
was tucked I was gonna say something
about him I finally did some of that
actually stayed on topic I think he came
to my wedding and then he had to go do a
gig and he does the gig and his wife
stayed and he comes back in a different
outfit like a pink jacket
he left my wedding and it's such a good
friend he came back again because he was
so happy for me because who the [ __ ]
else would want me then my wife and he's
just I was there in Philly at the at the
in Camden at the tweeter center it was
called when we were on the Opie and
Anthony virus tour
so it was Tracy Morgan myself louis c.k
is that the one where da Marrero got
heckled and he went on and he literally
attacked the crowd
it made Bill burr a legend that was when
bill I was reading their Liddell fiha I
was standing there I was at under the
[ __ ] monitor right through the
curtain that I was gonna come out I had
the sweet spot you know Bob will do it
like 25 minutes in the middle cuz I'm
yeah I was just a [ __ ] so then they put
me there and it was a sweet spot cuz you
take a lot of bullets coming up with a
Philly audience you know in the Jersey
audience and Bill I'd known him but I
actually known him through clubs but I
but he got out there and they were
booing him and he's so [ __ ] awesome
is the way he's made that whole [ __ ]
Boston brilliance and he just started to
pummel them back and said the worst
things you can say every inappropriate
thing you could possibly say calling
talking about their Chi stinks and the
Sixers and just you know thank you and I
watched it and I'm like this is [ __ ]
great for now and [ __ ] the Liberty Bell
exactly 15 minutes he did yeah and at
the end the boos were as loud as the
cheers I think he got a standing ovation
he didn't see it comes off stays like a
fighter he's all sweaty you see it was
[ __ ] horrible what the [ __ ] was that
I went
bill that was great are you kidding that
was [ __ ] amazing I've never helped
and that he still didn't believe me and
then I said you're gonna remember this
this is gonna you don't know what just
happened here if there's a tape of this
this is this is gonna change you don't
even know and I bring it up to him and
he's like he doesn't want to talk about
it but it is it was a defining moment
for his everything ya know he's he's
that guy that can just take a moment and
rant on things like he knows how to rant
better than anybody I know in terms of
like in the moment pick things apart and
peace and like he that's what his
podcast is one of the brilliant things
about his podcast he does it two times a
week and it's just him yeah it's just
him
which is crazy that he's got that sort
of muscle that he can just rant on
things by himself just starts reading
things and getting pissed off about this
you know what here's what the [ __ ]
problem is and then the heat just goes
off
and what's amazing is he knows what you
know what I what I what I know that
you're not he's not alone he's talking
there yes all of it so he's ranting to
people that love him and he knows they
love him he's comfortable and he loves
people yeah he's one of the sweetest
he's a great guy he's a great guy but he
does something that that Chappelle does
that I that I find them both so brave
that they know whether a point is and
they know we're there
their endgame is that's really well
phrased but it's like they dive into
they make a statement then they dive
into a pool with no water in it you know
metaphorically and then they know where
their exit is they know it and the items
out strong it's amazing yeah and
sometimes it's not quite as close but
then they still know how to fluff it
fluff the [ __ ] the final well David no I
don't take a subject and I mean it's one
of the cool things about being at the
store is you get to see like the
beginnings of those bits that a guy like
Chappelle or burr or anybody will start
out and then flesh it through and figure
it out and then tighten it up and then
by the time they're filming a special so
it's a weapon I got to go there more I
was starting to come in where in fact
you and I should have to bring me up oh
yeah it's close no I meant to come there
more disease a lot of people in the back
of that store I got stories but I mean I
see stories now people people [ __ ]
there do you get us in I got Kennison
his first spot at the store you got him
his first spot yeah tell me when on
stage yeah I met him in here's this uh
[ __ ] long tie a t5 80 I didn't have a
gig 83 84 I don't know and that's crazy
because 86 he was famous yeah what
happened was this so he'd already been
teed up for mitzi to watch but I had set
up the I told her to watch him
I met him in Houston and he was kicked
out of the comedy workshop in Houston
because of the [ __ ] he would say on
stage because he had been running his
you know 10th show of faith healing with
his brother bill and they would they
told me some [ __ ] up stories about
[ __ ] they would do it was a bit
charlatan and a bit trying to help
people but also talking about Jesus
quite a bit and he was cynical about it
but also very confused very conflicted
about it about what what is it because
his dying on on the ground supposedly he
looked up at the sky and was talking to
God
it's what bill tells us when I met him
Carla BOCES called the boat was there
Carl was there yeah Carl was there one
happen that's a whole complicated
non non story right now because it's a
heavy sparks my it's very [ __ ] heavy
yeah their stories really very high was
around yeah I was around for all of it I
I was there in the building for those
six seven years so what happened was
when I met him you would have had the
same response he goes they won't let me
work here I met him at the comedy
workshop
meet me at 1:00 in the afternoon he
shows me he posted he shows me this
telephone pole and he had put a picture
of himself on it and he kept putting up
they kept taking down he was in the
Houston Chronicle on the front page of
the arts entertainment and he dressed
himself because they banned him from the
club in a diaper and a crown of thorns
and blood coming from the crown of
thorns down his face with his eyes
rolled back in his head and said that he
had been persecuted just like Jesus from
playing the comedy worship but it's
pretty [ __ ] heavy you know and he had
made it quite a name for himself and had
a following there and when I don't know
what to do man I want to come out to LA
and I went well I'll help you out I was
playing the laugh stop in Houston and
that ROK's yeah I used to work that
place I liked it I did a guy named
Howard Oh
zone out mmm trying to remember anyway
this is our first dead air okay great
yeah I'm trying to remember what
happened what happened was Sam i sat
next to Mitzi in her booth he got on
stage
and he did the whole bit before he had
done the young comedians show that I was
on with rod he did Rodney's first young
comedians show and it was the whole
thing about you know the kid in that
whenever they do those World Vision
commercials with a starving kid and his
famous yeah the most famous one of the
most famous things that any comedians
done which was just a truism yeah which
is the cameraman can give him a sandwich
starving kid go get out of the desert go
to the word of the food that's a bit
that I use in a conversation with a guy
it was a weird conversation there was a
guy who wrote a book on comedy he was
teaching a comedy course at a university
and he was sitting here talking to me
and he said that the best comedy always
punches up I think is there was a time
when people really believed that
nonsense like that there was a formula
to comedy and that comedy should always
attack the the large power structures
and that the small people should be you
know elevated by comedy sitting here
telling me this like oh that's nonsense
like one of the greatest bits of all
time is literally about starving
children yeah there's no little Karlin
no further down that you could punch one
of his other great bits was about dead
people getting [ __ ] in the ass
remember that you have a bit about
homosexual necrophiliacs would pay money
to be with the freshest male corpse
those are two bits where you're punching
down as low as you can
someone's dad died and there's this
guy's [ __ ] him there's no further
punch down he was at stage in the main
room and he was doing a bit where he
says this is what happened to my
marriage and he had unplugged the mic is
my dick without he did not need a mic to
prove the point but he would lay on the
on the ground with his girth and he
would pretending he was having sex with
his wife from behind and he goes this is
what happened to my marriage and she as
because I'm trying to [ __ ] her and he's
like she's like we gotta fix the fence
it needs a new coat of paint but we
can't do you know you can't do that now
really I mean you could if you were Sam
you could do it again he couldn't she
was alive now he could do it first of
all he was uniquely he was uniquely
qualified for that kind of comedy
because you
he was short and he was fat and he was
going bald and wore a braid and the long
coat and he was hanging out with all the
rock and roll and pouring people the
coat he came onstage like he was a child
molester or something yeah I mean that
was look at that look at that picture
that's him at Bill Hicks
I love bow that's a crazy picture bill
was the sweetest most timid guy bill his
nails done there he's got a nail polish
on just when I was tips oh it's the
shadows but that was Sam was a sweetie
then so when you see him then I mean
when you go onstage he's that was part
of why it worked you know was that like
you know if he was John Mulaney and he
had that act you know handsome and slim
that you know now that pull off right
you had to be you had to look like you
got [ __ ] over he looked like he got
[ __ ] over and he did they did and he
did and he was doing faith-healing shows
and they told me a story where he had
been I wasn't gonna tell it but it's
[ __ ] weird yeah so there were two
healing people so this there in some
godforsaken place I don't know where and
he goes come up here and we're gonna
we're gonna heal you and like a
seven-foot tall guy with drawstring
pants and a t-shirt he we said he was
like Lenny from mice and men yeah there
was he was mentally impaired he said he
was gonna come up and he was gonna do
the whole thing with him and get out the
spirit and all that and as he's guys
coming up he's runs up to the stage and
he so tall he hits his head on a beam
and he splits his head open but he
doesn't fall down bill his brother will
tell you the story and the guy's pants
fall down and he had the biggest dick in
the world
and so his head is gushing blood and his
day
swinging and he's going like Young
Frankenstein Peter Boyle and it's
horrific ly upsetting and the way it's
been told to me I don't know if these
stories whisper down the lane is that
they went back to the same place after a
while the guy came back and he had some
other mishap I don't want to say he hit
his head again but he fell he just tried
to have a redo to get healed when I mean
I don't know what's more embarrassing
well if your head gets split up and but
the whole room can see you've got a
giant [ __ ] maybe it's a blessing and a
curse I don't know
there's probably a few gals that hit him
up after that but drawstring pants means
it's not a lot of cleanliness down on
the junk well you could wash them up if
you're a guy looking for a big dick like
there it is if a guy looking for a big
pick or maybe a guy you can trick in the
[ __ ] you yeah that would be the the
move or some you could play like you do
with a bat and baseball rights happens
to that make that sound again I can't do
I can't no and I can't roll my arse
either
but then the answer to Kennison how
quick he popped was after that set like
a week later rodney came in to see him
and I'd known Rodney ride he liked me I
like you man I met him at the in La
Jolla he came up to me you're funny man
you're June you're never gonna be happy
you got a fast mind you're all [ __ ] up
man you're never gonna be happy and he
was trying to clean up at La Coste and
he comes in he goes I can't do it man no
booze no Coke no pot no pills I can't do
it
he's with two women and and we and I
hung out with him all weekend he stated
that he kept coming to the condo and
hung out with me and Kennison he saw Sam
and I love this guy so I do the young
comedians special on HBO
I had a great set right before Sam I had
a 15-minute set Sam had a 15-minute set
I was in it for three and a half minutes
Sam was in it for fifteen minutes
because it was as a monumental it was
and then a year later he was in back to
school yeah so that's why it was a three
year deal with
that's crazy and he was a sweetheart
when I was 19 I worked as a security
guard at great woods Center for the
Performing Arts in Mansfield
Massachusetts and Rodney was there he
was backstage and I was like I didn't
get a chance to meet him but I was
backstage it was like a hallway it's
hard to know if this is a real memory
when you're 19 your brain is mush and it
was so long ago I got hit in the head a
lot but there I remember they were
talking about how he didn't have any
pants on
no never he had a bathroom yeah balls
out I remember him pacing back and forth
and looking down the hallway I know I
definitely saw him at least once and I
definitely saw him on stage with the
bathrobe on but I remember looking down
the hallway scenes kind of like how
crazy he doesn't have any pants on he's
gonna go onstage like this is what and
then him up there just didn't give a
[ __ ] I mean didn't give two had no [ __ ]
to give he was a movie star his income
at 58 by the way was Caddyshack that's a
long song and apparently smoked a
shitload of pot every day and when I
said sure my wife and just just murdered
I mean one punch line after another
punch line and people don't know the
story about him quit doing comedy for
years and became an aluminum siding
salesman he was born Jacob Cohen changed
it to Jack Roy and then a club owner
called him Rodney Dangerfield that's how
he was named by club I don't know I
don't know but he had a rough go yes
rougher go he had the no respect thing
was if you're gonna pick a brand the
catchphrase it wasn't that hatch phrase
it was his mantra
yeah well that that that made him you
know I got no respect I'll tell you no
respect at all loved he would have loved
you liked loved you because of [ __ ] he
always said and I've said this before so
I'm sorry if anybody has heard me say
this but he always said the key man is
you just go like a tank like a tank cuz
nobody wants you to make it everybody's
trying to stop you you just go like a
tank [ __ ] them all just go like a tank
cuz he had come up I took him so long to
get anywhere
and he would go on tonight's show and
there if you look at any of these clips
that they're running all over the
Internet
it's [ __ ] killer and Carson's hit in
the desk and it's just it's real special
well he was a special guy the store was
special too because it showed that you
know he was trying to make it and it
fell apart and then he took a long
didn't take like ten years off it was
luminous siding was many years yeah and
then he came back and became the biggest
[ __ ] movie star in the world but he
couldn't it took him to 58 and they put
him in Caddyshack and a lot of the jokes
were his yeah and and then a lot of them
I mean it was you know Harold Ramis and
stuff so it was the eighteen genius
movie and those movies were so good I
can Bill Murray in that Chevy was great
and everybody's great in that everyone
he's he's in the classroom and
kinnison's teach you know oh yeah
Kinnison played a [ __ ] off till
Vietnam vet who's screaming he just
wrote him into it yeah that's a great
movie back it's a [ __ ] great movie
and easy money was really great yeah oh
he had some classics man Caddyshack
he had some classics he was also I
officiated his funeral man it was pretty
pretty intense to put him away I was
with him in in the emergence and there
sorry I got a little in the intensive
care he was in a coma so I'd go in and
talk how it was you me past 84 it's
amazing he did all that coke and he made
it to 84 he stopped doing coke he just
liked pot but he did a lot of coke when
he stopped I think about ten years
before he died still amazing 74 years
old doing coke going I got another ten
years I'll tell you what
I can't how do you slow no booze no Coke
no pot no pills yeah I want to go back
to something you were talking about it's
completely off comedy topic cuz but
we'll come back to it I don't know it's
your show I don't know if our structure
Trump Trump's nice the book I got you on
passage the it was just about empathy
you know it's just about why what's
wrong with him psychologically
you know and when you whenever you see
someone that seeks power like that seeks
seeks that kind of adulation that's that
kind of spotlight like what what is
causing that like what is that you know
what what makes someone want to be that
person is like you're fired you don't
see any love out of them a sweetness
there's I think as a as a nation at this
time we need we need someone who has got
a real message not some [ __ ] canned
speech that's prepared by a focus group
where they figured out all the right
beats to hit and but they're not even
doing the writings easy I mean they're
Mount Rushmore speech could have had
five six minutes in it that could have
added some people to it well it's he's
not that guy Obama was that guy Obama if
if Obama was stuck in the situation I
really truly believe he could have given
a speech that made us all feel like
we're gonna be okay 100% 100% he was an
incredibly good cheerleader and was
empowering and it was also it's like you
knew his story his story's the opposite
of Trump's story Trump stories he comes
from a rich father you know the father
gives him money he starts his businesses
he's known for being kind of shady and
you know Obama's the opposite he comes
from a single mom grows up in a ye you
know is uh it's just different you like
you know that he he's gone through some
[ __ ] to get there and had compassion
yeah we need that we need someone who
sees that we're hurting you know that
this nation is [ __ ] hurting man you
see what we're talking about earlier
with the cops and all these murders that
are happening in New York City and
Chicago's got record murders oh it's
it's Tourette's crazy
yesterday was horrific it every day is
and there's no real hope in sight in
terms of the economy because
everything's getting more lockdown like
today what was that what got passed down
today in California they went back to
almost stage one they shut down all the
what did they shut down yeah my yoga
teachers been trying to get me to go to
yoga I'm like it's not a hot room I do
it do it online I do it at home bro calf
on you close to indoor rest to close
into a restaurants movie theaters and
bars statewide as coronavirus cases rise
did say gyms as well hair salons
barbershops fitness centers worship
services oh my god worship services
so that's churches guys yup everything
well it's got it worked when they
suppress it it works in countries they
know they keep saying but it's okay to
protest you can't but then they're
saying that I then you hear and I don't
know where I hear it it might be left
information that a lot of protesters
were protected didn't get sick is what
I'm hearing I can't believe that does
that make any sense doesn't make any
sense they don't want to say that these
incredibly significant historical
protests have created an uptick in the
virus that will likely lead to deaths
they don't want to say that but both
those things are true
those those protests are very important
it's very important and they may and and
they're moving the needle yeah and the
life is gonna change so that is a
positive for people that have been
neglected for so long but all at once
it's like some [ __ ] supreme weird
litmus on the whole every whole universe
it's like and I don't think it's a
sci-fi I don't think it's over I think
we're gonna get hit with a couple more
wacky moments yeah well a meteor that's
not far or a solar flare that takes out
the power grid we just don't want to
lose our Wi-Fi that's all that we called
the wi-fi's first I thought this was
germ warfare is what I thought this was
I didn't think this was and wet markets
are open again is is well it's not from
the wet market that's where I want to
know Tommy all indications seem to point
to the fact that this was a virus that
had been manipulated I had Brett
Weinstein on my podcast he's a biologist
and he in terms that I will not be able
to recreate explained all the different
factors
that when they examined the virus would
not be very likely to have happened in
nature and certainly not as quickly as
they had that the all these different
aspects of the virus point to the fact
that it had been something that had been
manipulated the fact that there was a
level 4 lab in Wuhan this is not you
know people love to use the term
conspiracy theory but this this level 4
lab where they studied corona viruses
that come from bats is there it's in
Wuhan why they study why they that same
lab had been 2 years ago had been in
trouble for violating safety protocols
they look china's it's it's not america
it's not it's not the same and they do
things differently over there
they're completely intertwined with
their government they can get away with
things that we can't get away with here
and they you know they don't have a
strict protocol when it comes to
handling diseases well you know the the
word of a street is often that it's
wealthy people wanting to have their
endangered species fix that's what
you're here
what do you mean that the wet market bat
is like a delicacy and that's how it got
spread i've have not heard that i don't
know if that's true i don't know where
imagine it would be more like people are
starving and they need to eat whatever
they can eat and they eat bats because
it laid out like lobsters at the farmers
market that's what I was picturing that
probably safer it's not what happened I
don't believe that's what happened in
Brett Weinstein is very careful in not
saying that this is definitely what
happened but he he put points to all the
factors that lead to this very likely
conclusion that this is something that
accidentally got out of a lab is the
reason why it's so contagious that
spreads so easily that it takes on so
many different forms and has so many
different reactions and so many
different people it's almost like we're
dealing with a bunch of different
diseases any time you mate humanity with
an animal there's a serious problem I'm
not talking sexually although I've seen
a couple of goats in my life that kind
of had a twinkle you you had a smile why
are you doing that because you knew you
shouldn't do it and you did it and I
couldn't help it I mean I work out well
but you know it didn't work out well at
all
no but you're enjoying that but the
other thing is I wanted for the kids out
there listening don't [ __ ] animals no
don't forget is that okay to put that
out there what if that animal really
wants you to [ __ ] it that's what I was
saying a goat with a gleam in his eye
this is where I double down on not
working and what about a small animal no
that's mean [ __ ] something that could
kill you if you're gonna have the balls
[ __ ] elephant like a bear yeah [ __ ] a
large predator yeah don't don't [ __ ]
something that you're you're the bully
hold out rabbit down and [ __ ] him so
it's the revenant I mean yes what he did
was get inside a bear literal not sort
of yeah eventually right took a while
right yeah I think this is how I tried
this is how I deal with how horrible
this is this I go to a place that's
[ __ ] asinine and that's what my dad
would do or just stupid just stupid
because the I know that China is
completely [ __ ] up with this and they
they're apparently out of control and
they don't know how to stop what's
happening is what I'm hearing also well
it's doing better than we're doing
china's they've got it way more under
control than we do how do we know that
though cause if we don't you know they
lie about everything
the other thing about what's weird is
like why why did it go so badly here
yeah the UK the UK's basically that
restaurants are open again New Zealand
has zero viruses now they're back to
normal I mean they're not letting
anybody in but there they are literally
back to a no virus situation it's like
the resistance of the United States is
down because so many not the resistance
but the our immune system is down
because there's so much hatred there's
so much [ __ ] weird [ __ ] I wonder what
would have happened I mean it's really
crazy that you know these you know that
expression the wings of a butterfly
could become a hurricane yeah but what
would have happened if that George Floyd
thing didn't happen if that day did not
go down that way if it was just a normal
day if maybe George Floyd just hopped in
the patrol car you know or maybe didn't
give them that counterfeit $20 bill
never got arrested
what the [ __ ] would we be looking at
it's kind of amazing when you really
know it's it's a change of history in
one moment in um in a instant and in an
incident between two people between one
cop in one man and then the world sees
it because one girl 17-year old girl
filmed it she she puts it up the whole
world sees the horror of that guy
leaning on that man's neck with his
other people standing by and then the
world of sports or our country explodes
but imagine where would we be it'd be
really interesting to see two different
timelines you know see a timeline where
that never happens I think it was ground
to happen anyway we've been you mean but
that was so egregious it was so yes oh
hey know that that's the point that's a
plat laughs yeah to this explosion where
as if there was nothing like that I mean
because the the guy who got shot by
those vigilantes was just a couple of
weeks before that remember in Georgia I
do
if this George Floyd thing that was like
seeing the ball up you know and then
this George Floyd thing happens and boom
the powder keg blows I think the enough
is enough moment happened and
everybody's holed up in quarantine and
everybody can't pay their rent and
nobody can do anything but watch all
this [ __ ] of all this racism and all
this all of our bureaucrats viewing a
bunch of lies and garbage at everybody
my favorite part of it was the black and
white video the actors made to try to
fix it no longer stand by imagine with
the imagined video also that was the
beginning of the corona virus this was
after that these these actors hadn't
worked in months and they desperately
needed attention so they ought to carry
that stupid [ __ ] video do you see
what Jim Norton said about the imagined
video nobody thought he said when I saw
that video I got all choked up because I
tried to hang myself
so embarrassing well you know there's
something great about people that have a
heart for it that are well-known whether
it be acting or sports or whatever music
that people are that look up to those
people but it's saturated when it's just
people doing it because they're getting
publicity that's all they're doing it
that's why they're doing it they're
doing it because they this might be an
opportunity to let other people know
that they're awesome that's that's what
they're doing and that's their fake way
of pretending they have a heart it just
doesn't look do you know I mean there
has to be some hard in there so of
course of course it's not like they're
evil
but that's nurses ISM there's a there's
a there's a certain amount of narcissism
there that's foul it smells bad it's
like when you know you open up some
leftovers like I can't eat this that's
what it is it's got a smell that's 100
percent right yeah it's it's the smell
of narcissism the smell of ego to smell
the preposterous idea that you're gonna
sing your way out of people dying and
that's what we're living right now
that's what we're listening to right now
but when I see Jared Kushner and I'm
sure he's a delightful guy I bet he's
not you know I I was being totally
facetious to hope I oak great I think
he's awesome oh I love him pinkie swear
BFF but what what it is about he really
looks like central casting to play the
Nazi in a movie he so looks like he's
gonna have that collar on and he's so
good yeah exactly yeah yeah but but
apparently he's running the whole show I
don't know that's crazy I don't believe
I don't know what the [ __ ] I don't know
what to believe
anywhere I just want some where are we
gonna get truth where are we ever gonna
get it weren't they mad that he was the
one saying that the coronavirus was
gonna be nothing and to not yes he was
one of the many like the bullfrogs in
there and Mitch McConnell and Lindsey
Graham they all look like something out
of dr. doom II imagine you're the
president and you like what's gonna
happen here hey let me go ask that guy
who's married to my daughter he seems
pretty smart
that's married to my daughter my
daughter my daughter my daughter
girlfriend wife wants to be imagine that
to imagine that he hires his family well
that's a that's a monarch I mean that's
yeah that's a dictatorship in a monarchy
but it's just does the only people
probably because he wants love and I
think they do love him they must love
him and I've known people that know him
I'm sure you do too that have said I
worked with him he was horrible and I've
also talked to people that are hung out
with him he was great yeah
I've talked to people that know him that
really liked him yeah I've read that too
and then it's a performance the moment
it happens it's a performance it's well
Ross told me that Ross told me that he
had a good time with them when they were
roasting him and he Ross told me that he
was telling him like listen when they're
making fun of you you gotta laugh like
Ross just likes that he liked him maybe
you're right buddy yeah maybe that's a
good point
it's a real good point it's just it's
just a sad time and we got it we have to
punch through it that's what I'm also is
the nature this business is that the way
politicians are taken apart their past
is taken apart things are taken out of
context they make these attack pieces
they look into their finances they look
into their past relationships they try
to find every [ __ ] little piece of
something that might indicate there's a
character flaw nobody wants to go
through that so no person who's really
like a person that you'd want to be
president wants to be president as few
of them already Flanders tulsi gabbard
there's a few that I looked at I said I
could like Tulsi Gabbard she's young I
could see her running this country are
really good and I think she would do an
amazing job at this she's a genuinely
good person right and a real leader and
I think you know Bernie has some
interesting ideas and I would I would
love to see what would happen if we went
like with some of those ideas
particularly like fixing inner cities
man doing something to fix these crime
ridden drug addled gang infested
communities that have been stuck like
that for decades and decades
to parentless in Festus I mean that's it
that's one thing that I that we
hopefully goodness will come from is
that they will send people to help with
mental illness and drug rehabilitation
and guidance and if that can happen how
does that happen how do you send people
into the depths of Chicago where a lot
of the pandemic of that kind of lack of
love and it has to be done locally and
it has to be done in each individual
place by someone who understands the
community it has to be done locally in
each individual city each individual
city has unique problems I don't think
you could use Baltimore's solution on
Detroit I think you have to have your
own solution you're right for each
individual place based on people that
actually understand how they got how it
got to where it is and what could be
done and mayors and their regime need to
be heroes they need to be people and the
other thing is you were saying you know
whatever you get looked into every
single scrap of your life comes up you
did something wrong you dated someone
wrong you paid someone you did something
you did drugs sometime I think that
should be right there when you come out
of the gate when you're up for you give
get give just give the schematic on the
person just in I want to run for
president here's all the [ __ ] I did
there's no [ __ ] tax evasion there's I
didn't know she was 19
you know I didn't know that her mom was
my girlfriend [ __ ] like that
yeah I never put my finger in that dog
that pictures is photoshopped yeah you
couldn't help yourself I don't know I
mean that's how diseases start but no
you just get sick you don't get a
disease maybe you don't get sick I think
helps people out there could give a [ __ ]
mmm you know people out in the mountains
looking at their sister well you know in
that way I had this is the kind of
person I was when I was 21 so Jay Leno's
at the store my first night did stand-up
Letterman brings me up that's how my old
man stories Wow
so this is my first night Mitch he said
you got to quit I was going to USC are
we talking here
seventy-eight Mitzie said I was gonna go
to USC film school I got into their grad
program because I won a student Oscar
for a documentary I made about my nephew
having his face reconstructed I was
going to go serious filmmaking that's
what I wanted and I was also stand-up
since I was 17 so midsi said now don't
go there work here
you work here you're good I'll put you
and you work here and you won't get paid
but work here Owen okay because that
night when I moved to LA and I quit grad
school like the day I quit USC grad
school I went there for three days I
went up at the store
Letterman brought me up the lineup was
Leno Michael Keaton Billy Crystal
Geoff Altman Argos Pryor went up later
in the evening is on one [ __ ] night
that's insane and you're part of the
reason that place came back you and a
bunch of the people that came in you
brought it back I mean it was not long
ago that place was gone
yeah it wasn't one good now it wasn't
looking good no you you did that that's
that's the empowerment that takes a
strong thing to go wait this place is
history and I like these rooms I need to
do comedy what what was I want to know
what was your decision-making process
and how did you find because you were
already on your way to wherever you
wanted to make your playground well I
was gone for seven years you know I was
gone from 2007 to 2014 and that was the
that Carlos Mencia incident that I had
at the store yet I got banned and not
even by mitzi I got banned by the former
management and there's just some weird
[ __ ] going on behind the scenes and they
were created so where were you worked
out before then I was at the store oh
there's a store from 94 to 2007 I moved
to LA in 94 and the first thing I did is
go to the store that was Mecca when I
was in Boston and I was an open mic er I
heard about the store oh yeah in 1988 I
started and that was when Sam Kinison
was huge and you know I start I
literally started comedy that's right
when I left so I missed you I missed you
94 right well I always wanted to ask you
what it was like because when you did
Full House you basically had to stop
doing stand-up because you were on this
I still clean it he still did it yeah
and as I started to morph and I started
to get really [ __ ] up onstage and I
was it was [ __ ] up how [ __ ] up on I
would go okay that's what I'm doing to
her in the day and here's I know when
you did news radio they wanted you not
to do stand-up as much is that kind of
no not really no the only thing that
ever happened on news radios one of the
producers said why he's still doing the
comedy you're an actor now like it was
if it was a great thing and I was
horrified I was like what yeah oh like
what I'm gonna stop doing stand-up for
this you know that's because they don't
understand they think a lot of people
use used and used stand-up to get a show
to get a writing gig to get something
and I'm like I can't stop being one I am
one yeah that's part of my hard drive
well it was the most fun too like they
were asking me to do this thing that I
was basically like I never taken any
acting classes and I just gotten a
development deal from MTV half-hour
comedy hour right and they said do you
want to be on a sitcom like okay and so
they made me like get an acting coach I
took a few classes but it was really
annoying and then next thing you know
I'm out here in LA on a sitcom and so
when they said like why are you doing
stand-up here in action I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about right you
don't you've never killed I'm like
you're saying this guy's you never
killed they also didn't believe in -
it's at that point you can't do three
things you can't do four things I'm
sorry you can only do one thing I was
also that I started working for the UFC
and when I started working for the UFC
they were acting like I was doing porn
what are you doing and I was like yeah
I'm going to Alabama to do post-fight
interviews for a cage fighting event no
the [ __ ] is wrong with you that's
because you're [ __ ] original they
don't know what that is well it was just
no one had done it
right there was no nobody good slash
Cagefighting commentators find me
another whatever but it was just one of
those things where like I was like I
don't care I'm gonna do this cuz I want
to do this and then they were like you
really shouldn't do this like this
probably bad for your career I'm like
whatever I don't even know what that
means I'm just gonna do what I like to
do tell me again where you had left off
about the the Mencia thing with the
karlon so he made some sort of sneaky
backdoor deal with the store to have
them banned me and he would put his name
on the marquee which he never did would
do before like he would do spots they
would just show up and bump people that
was this thing you like to just show up
and he didn't didn't let them put his
name on the marquee and sell tickets
with his name because he would do big
venues around town this was around you
know the mind of Mencia days he was a
big star you know he was selling out
large theatres he was doing really well
and I wasn't doing as well with stand-up
I was on fear factor and I was doing
pretty good with comedy but I was mostly
doing clubs he was more advanced
career-wise if I'm being honest and so
when they said that to me that I was
banned and I knew it was wrong
I'm like I know I go you guys are your
cell art you sell art this is what you
sell like use this you have an art store
it's just it's a spoken art and you are
you're basically taking the side of
someone who's stealing a vampire you
give a vampire of all the other
performers not just a vampire but
someone would who if you were going
onstage he would go on before you and do
your closing bit and then bring you up
there was a lot of dark [ __ ] going on
people were scared they had lights they
would flick in the back of the room when
he was there to let you know if he wants
these guys would just stop doing their
act I was a very was not good it was not
good it was it was accentuated by his
celebrity when he became famous it got
WAY worse but it always existed he was
always a thief and so I I said okay I'm
not coming back I'm let you know like
you think this is gonna be like a
two-week deal or something like this you
can go [ __ ] yourself I'm not coming back
so just make make this decision
understand this is not this is not a
temporary thing where
to ban me for a little while and I'm
going back and forth with the manager
well mid-cycle don't tell me mitts he
said because I was on the phone with
Mitzi an hour ago before this and I told
Mitzi what was going on
I told Mitzi that we are gonna make this
video about him stealing material
because it was a horrible situation
there and I told her I'm like I go you
know this is just what it is she was all
right just keep away from him she was
when you want to go up and I go when you
want to put me up she was all right how
about 10:30 I go perfect I love you
because I love you too it's last time I
talked to her last time I talked to her
then they call me an hour later and say
I'm banned and I'm like what are you
talking about I just got off the phone
with Mitzi I go who's running the
[ __ ] store you were running this har
you're you you're running the store I
work for you get the [ __ ] out of here
and so I got furious and I just started
working the improv and I did the ice
house and I just said okay this is what
I do now I don't work at the store
anymore and the store I put the store's
phone number on my my blog and told
everybody the whole story and I'm like
feel free to call them and let him know
how I feel and it was a ghost town there
for years you know what yeah it did I
crashed that place yeah yeah yeah so
what brought you back
Ari Shaffir was doing his comedy special
he was filming and add an atom egit you
know Adam I'd known add I like Adam I
love Adam and he was he'd been on the
podcast before - I've seen him Adam was
at the Tempe improv years before that
and I became friends with him when I
worked there and then he came over and
started being the talent coordinator at
the store and they came to visit me at
the improv he said we'd love to have you
at the store there's like Tommy doesn't
work there anymore he's gone was the
manager that I had the issue with right
and Mincey had long been just he had
long been outcast from the comedy
community like that video and the
subsequent all these other comedians
coming out and telling stories about him
everything fell apart and this is what I
told them was gonna happen I was like
this is not it's not gonna go away this
is real this is not like people make
mistakes they accidentally do someone's
bit because they forget it was someone's
bit or you come up with do come up with
the same thing people yeah there's a lot
but there there's good people and then
there's people
that are victimizing people and he was
one of those that was victimizing people
and what the worst I've ever seen and so
this had happened and I knew when Adam
came to visit me at the improv I knew
why I knew Adam was a good guy and I
thought about it but I was like I can't
I'm not I can't I can't go back there
and then Ari was doing his special and
our was filming his special in the bar
and Ari was one of my best friends and I
had been friends with Ari from the time
that he was a doorman and I was like he
had gone through this journey of being a
doorman - I started taking him on the
road with me so I take him on the road
and we would do all these gigs together
and now here he is he's got his own
television show and he's doing a [ __ ]
Comedy Central special and he's filming
it at the store I'm like I gotta be
there so I came there on Tuesday night
he was filming on Wednesday I came in on
Tuesday night and I was there for ROS
battle and Jeff Ross introduced me to
the crowd
and I got to see Rose battle and it was
Wild Rose battle was wild it was so
beautiful was like it was creative and
it was fun and it was packed I was there
one night being a judge Jeff brought me
and said Bob you got to come down you
don't know you don't know it's wonderful
if it comes back it still is so cool but
it'll come back and then the next night
I came back and I saw Ari
I've watched already film is special and
I said okay I'm gonna start doing shows
and so I think you know like a couple
days later I did my first show back
there that was it then you were there
and you were playing almost every night
of the week was there a lot yeah until
the lockdown I was there many days week
I'm gonna come back and do it right and
sign up put my name on the thing I do
drop-ins but they're five minutes I
don't know you don't want to drop in I
know I don't I don't I want to do sets
and what I was doing to drop it it's
just it would be just - I wasn't sure
you know I wasn't sure that I wanted to
go up and be part of a lineup is it
competitive to people take your stuff to
people no there's none of that there now
there's none of that that was my you
know I've PTSD from eight years right
and I was at a love affair with Mitzi I
was like a nephew to her
so I was kind of like family even at her
funeral I was like family even though I
hadn't been around but there was one
time in Vegas where I had a weird
experience and I was trying to keep
somebody sober and I had to stay up all
night to keep them sober so that she
didn't find out and as a result I hadn't
slept and I had a week set in Vegas at
the dunes and then after the set she
came backstage and said you've lost it
you're not funny anymore
oh no and that was like you don't say
that to a sensitive jou comic neurotic
[ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] though
dude she had zero filter no and and you
know what happened it hurt me and it's
just like you teach in martial arts to
the kids it's like well I better get
[ __ ] funny yeah I better get funny
again and I just have to use another
ain't no excuses no you get it and I
just worked harder and harder and now I
mean I want to do I might do some
drive-ins I don't know what I'm gonna do
but I I'm enjoying the podcast thing
because I get to and I call people and
talk to them and that's an interplay
with people good to [ __ ] around a little
and I have some guests that you've had
that I love people that are friends and
but the point is I'm born this I'm born
to do this you're born to do this and
she was just teaching me something and
she loved me and I loved her but she got
really sick sigh and you know it was
really tragic some people hated her and
some people loved her all the way to the
end I loved her I know she helped me
yeah she helped me to me who wasn't for
her hoots when I became a paid regular
that was like the most important day of
my life at that moment like I was like
holy [ __ ] I'm a real comedian I'm a paid
regular see I didn't know what that
meant
I showed up one night and then they put
on the website Bob Saget paid regular
and I wrote to the email or I don't know
I texted somebody whoever did the thing
I went you don't have to call me a paid
regular I mean you know you can say I
showed up yeah he goes no no you don't
understand it
honor I like but I don't take the pay I
never take hey I'm paid regular I don't
but I didn't realize it is a rite of
passage like a badge of honor it is it
was stripes it was something important
when that happened I was like oh my god
because like I said when I started out
in 88 the Comedy Store was Mecca that
was the place like I oh I wanted to be
there that was where Richard Pryor
performed that was where Kinison
performed those where Hicks performed I
wanted to go there
and when I was there I was actually
there it was a dark time and I was there
in 94 was a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I went in
when it was over when it was empty I
mean you know 20 P it was socially
distanced well it was a there's a
perfect for now a bad run for about six
years where it wasn't very good from 94
to around 2000 and somewhere around 2000
started picking up again if Paulie
Paulie really stepped in and Peter Peter
did a lot right well it's just better
talent kids started coming around right
that's how it was
it's like there was a lot of guys who
would I think there was a week this is
my own personal theory and I'm only
basing it on the timeline of kinnison's
death Kinnison left the comedy store
somewhere around like 90 and then he
died somewhere around like 92 somewhere
around there 93
and then the you know so many guys had
gone off and done sitcoms and like Jim
Carrey had gone off and done movies and
in living color and there wasn't there
wasn't that many people there and then
there was also a lot of really bad
talent there was a lot of that's that
that's that is a fact there are people
that could have been accountants and
instead chose comedy as a career and
they learned how to walk the stage yes
and they learned how to hold the mic and
they learned how to talk to the audience
right they're like a plumber they learn
a trade it's not and they weren't even
good at it that the performer you don't
want the plumber that's gonna blow your
toilet up yeah the plumber puts the
wrong gasket and it runs so I saw a lot
of those guys and I was really
disappointing like I was like one of my
first nights there I remember there was
like 15 20 people in the audience the
the acts were terrible I was like this
is so weird this is the Comedy Store
that's why I stayed away because it made
me sad but then
every now and then like Martin Lawrence
would show up every now and then Damon
Wayans would show up every now and then
da Marrero would show up every now and
then someone would show up and I showed
up I wasn't there when you were there
that sucks
I didn't see you there for many many
years many years but that's why I was
asking about like the full house days
was it hard that's interesting because
it's great because you were you had a
dirty act blue until after and full
house in the video show were
simultaneous and they were family you
know seven o'clock at night on a Sunday
I'm hosting videos I can't say here's
another [ __ ] video you know you can't
do that right and I didn't say [ __ ] that
much in fact few years ago dice called
me go Saget I gotta tell you something
to see each other but also you know what
man you stole my [ __ ] after you after
full House ended
you stole my I said what did I steal
well you didn't used to say [ __ ] as much
oh I stole [ __ ] was he joking kind of
but not really with anyone at the tour
with me so it was kind of like si dice
always pranking you I love him he's
always half [ __ ] with you I started
going on the road because of dice I was
just doing the store and this is when I
was on news radio and one day he were in
the back gonna say you should go on the
road and I'm like yeah he goes yeah
you're funny he goes you don't wanna be
[ __ ] beholding these [ __ ] he
goes these [ __ ] in the movies
and their shows he goes he goes you go
on the run we gave him a good living you
know I was thinking about I was like why
don't I go on the road so I just started
booking gigs I literally just listened
to him it's first of all you know I'm 27
years old I can't believe dice is
talking to me right and then I'm talking
to dice like and then he tells me to go
on the road it was like he's right why
don't I go on the road so I started
doing gigs here and there you know and
then when I really started going on the
road like we're really was when I left
the store that 2007 time when I left the
store that's when I started touring
that's what I really started touring
because I was kind of angry too
I was like you know I put all that time
into that place and and I was I thought
what we were doing like that Mencia
thing I thought that was we're doing the
right thing I thought that was a real
problem
and so when that was the reaction was
like okay I'm gonna show you
[ __ ] I had this this attitude
like I'm gonna show you and then I did
my best work ass there's nothing wrong
with that yeah that was my best work was
after that because I was you know my
best my first real big special was 2009
which is two years after that and then
you know and I don't have any hate for
that dude and I hope he gets better
like I hope he's doing great I really do
I think I think he has learned his
lesson from hope he has I hope people
forgive him too I don't I think that's a
problem you know I think many people
have had it you know some very famous
people have had it no I don't mean that
yeah many people have had that like
Robin Wright you know a lot of people
had that that and his and his loss is so
and his talent is so gigantic that he
was just a vacuum cleaner of stuff he
didn't yeah yeah and I loved him beyond
he was he's he was so yeah he said he's
he's from every hundred years of Robin
comes here this is what it's I don't you
you brought up what was going on doing
those family shows and then doing Stan
yeah Richard Jeni comes into play Harris
it's kind of an interesting thing you
brought him up cuz he hits me in the
solar plexus I did a special while the
two shows were in the top ten full house
and America's Funniest Home Videos such
long names to say they sound like I'm
saying porn when I say the names of it
[ __ ] it's like dirty to me
full house oh that's a filthy Bob but I
love doing family entertainment that's
my many different sides I love doing
stuff the whole family can watch
together I don't look at that and go oh
[ __ ] that that's [ __ ] you know
that's that's not the cynical guy that
can come out and be blue for the sake of
blue I wasn't blue for the sake of blue
I just did what I did you know just like
you did what you did you know you're UFC
stuff it's like I wasn't doing anything
athletic but but to I did an HBO special
and it did well but in the ratings or
whatever but
was not good and I I made it so you
can't see it and Richard Jeni loved it
and he would say to me I loved that
special and I was I was saying [ __ ]
it but it was like an hour long and it
took a half an hour it was about me
being in a dream trying missing my gig
so I was trying to make a film because I
want to be a filmmaker and then the next
half-hour was basically a half hour
stand-up and I just didn't do any of it
right you know and but there were a
couple really funny moments and a couple
good bits and Richard told me he thought
it was one of the funniest specials and
most inventive that he'd ever seen and
that I was always thrown by that and and
and I started to get more like well what
I want to do in standup and I was like I
just want to make people laugh I just
went up and then when the show's ended I
started directing some stuff and then I
did a special called that ain't right
and that was the HBO special that upset
a lot of people and also put me in
Rolling Stone and a Newsweek and all
that was because it was dirty a lot
because I was I was at my check matter
as well know yeah a little bit I used
[ __ ] as a verb a few times I don't I you
know you know if it's expressive right
but it was your shoot I mean it's what I
said because that's what you had always
been doing but they didn't expect that
out of you because they wanted full
house and America's Funniest Home but
who would go to see that what am I going
to do hug people and clean you know well
they wanted a sort of Howie Mandel thing
look how he's blue he is blue sometimes
but not anymore no stand up yeah so I'm
at the Laugh Factory was actually
talking about the dangers of doing a bit
that could get him fired from the show
oh he had she talked about that on stage
that if he says anything wrong I mean
he's on the squeakiest of squeaky family
entertainment you know he went from Deal
or No Deal to this other thing he's
doing now what does the America's Got
Talent or yeah yeah you mean he's I've
been talking to him a lot he's a great
guy he's a great guy and he's had a lot
of mental health issues that he talked
about in a book and his OCD is just the
outskirts of it how about
now with the [ __ ] coronavirus hold on
a germophobe yeah have the whole world
right Kylie so by the way somebody wrote
that down the whole world is Howie
Mandel now yeah I says something like
he's a prophet
I forget who it was I forget who wrote
it was Gaffigan someone someone said
that like that someone had a glove I
love Jim he's great but anyway so you
know I don't know why people think that
you're like a character you play in
something well because he played that
character for a long time for so long
and this was pre social media this is
pre podcast they just associate like
Bill Cosby okay for the longest time
people thought Bill Cosby but I got it
out today bill always was offended that
I talked blue on stage cuz he said you
don't need it and when I would see him I
would almost hear Lucky's saying
[ __ ] in between what would it
bill cosby think about Kennison I want
to know that I would have loved to seen
that I'm sure he just he just
disapproved anything blue but the truth
is look what he acted out in his real
life I would do it that is why yeah
that's the boys club that he was in my
boys club or I hate to say that because
it's so misogynistic but it was a guy
that looks like you I know what I look
like I look like your dentist your
accountant or somebody maybe your
gynecologist if it's a good week but not
yours but but I'll continue I swear I
just had a moment of doing like 10 of
those that go nowhere but but the truth
of it is for me to say that is the joke
for me and that gets nowhere also so I
have to have content and the more
specials I did and the more I've done
stand-up like I was about to shoot a new
one this year I've got like an hour and
a half of stuff of course so everybody's
gonna have 12 minutes of kovin but I
don't know what it's gonna be but it was
really I was about to talk about racial
injustice ready to go cuz I've got all
this stuff when I was a kid and
segregation and I was living it and
didn't understand it when I was 6 7
years old in Virginia so it was like I
started to have more much more in
much more intent in what I want to do
right now and make people laugh I got to
throw a dick joke again just to make
myself happy
well stand-up comedy is supposed to be
here's the world through my eyes
whenever some other comic comes along
and tells you not to do your version of
reality then go eat [ __ ] and usually
there's something wrong with them and
that's obviously the case of Bill Cosby
there's something wrong with him
a hundred percent his need to have
everyone deliver this g-rated comedy was
you know he was he had some dark dark
[ __ ] going on the back of his head and I
[ __ ] looked up to him so much when I
was young I'd watch him on I spy with
Robert Culp and it was just you probably
didn't watch it back because I'm older
he was so great and then you know he got
his doctorate after just two years they
gave him a free one at Temple on with
the temple university also but I
graduated and I didn't you know
tranquilize people and ejaculate
congratulations thank you for into the
non ejaculation clause but he you know
you can't preach and then be full of
[ __ ] it's less when he got away with for
his whole life though I think that's how
he like covered his tracks like nobody
would believe it who raped you Bill
Cosby oh go on there's no way that's
what they would think and I guarantee
you that was part of what was the hustle
was it's like a priest I give if no one
knew that priests rape kids and then you
came home and said mom the priest raped
you me your mama Billy what the [ __ ] Boy
Scouts look I mean there's a [ __ ] ad
right now yeah I can't believe this an
ad I'm glad does it matter what do you
mean there's an ass commercial if you if
you've been sexually molested
Scoutmaster yeah yeah
so all this [ __ ] that's that's the
cleaning that seems to be happening
that's positive that people are getting
called on stuff that's been going on for
thousands of years and in this country
for hundreds of years and terrible
terrible terrible [ __ ] so that I that's
a good calling out that's a good I mean
well that's calling out is one way to
look at it but what's really happening
is the the lines between reality in for
truth information and people like how
how accessible is truth it's their way
it's there's way less distance to travel
to find out reality than they used to be
and we we're remapping our version of
the world because of that and you know
this is what we're seeing with
everything with police brutality so
we're seeing with taxes that's what
we're seeing with with government and
the environment and you know climate
change and fill-in-the-blank every city
every woman demmick it's just a giant
[ __ ] representation of all of it
what's a wake-up call to all of us that
there has been way less funding and
planning and strategy to deal with
pandemic viruses than should have ever
been put in place Bill Gates warned us
about this in 2015 I know a lot of
people think Bill Gates is the devil now
for some reason I do pay attention that
yeah they think Bill Gates is like
trying to depopulate the world or some
[ __ ] I don't know I don't know whether
to get off Facebook tick tock I don't
know them
there's a guy in when they were trying
to keep Huntington Beach or Long Beach
open they would know wasn't Long Beach
it wasn't Huntington Beach it was
Huntington Beach it's a Republican area
right so they had all these people in
the street we're not gonna wear a mask
we're not gonna stay inside it was the
early days of the pandemic right and
this guy's going you know do not wear a
mask do not give in Bill Gates of the
devil he was yelling this is like pre
George Floyd all that [ __ ] now remember
that topped off the madness of that
particular moment like Bill Gates the
devil think I mean and Microsoft the guy
we wear sweaters sound like it was crazy
to listen to people do believe we're all
over the [ __ ] place people are all
over and it's like one sides over here
so liberal that I'm not allowed to say
anything I'm talking about just how it
not as a narcissist but as a human
artist how it affects me how it affects
you and then everybody's over here so
far right
it's fundamentalists on both sides can't
we just cut off the little hand
on each side and just have just a or
Cantwell everybody have a if there has
to be a dream disc listen it's not gonna
this is this is how change happens you
have to correct Polar's you have to have
polar opposites yes this is just an
electron de mentalism it man it is yeah
the same thing you see on the left is
you see on the right
their ideology varies but what their
goal is is the same their goal is
compliance they want you to listen they
want to have power and control and then
there's people that are fairly
reasonable that can see other people's
perspectives that lean towards the
middle those are the healthy people but
these people that want you to use 78
different gender pronouns and they only
want to give money expect keep up I've
made so many mistakes it's not mistakes
man well I did a thing in Austin which
we both love and I did a thing for the
ally coalition and it's it's for the LG
I always [ __ ] it up it's LGBT Q cubed Q
is questioning or queer it change was
yeah its questioning or or queer at that
moment hey now you know is in there too
what is that asexual I got thrown in the
mix I'm fine with that so I'm not
throwing I'm not I did a joke at that
game I did it call I did it for them
because they're a wonderful organization
that helps a lot of people and it was it
was I loved it and I was with Jay
Pharoah who I loved being with and bunch
of people bunch of comedians were on the
thing and I was the I guess the
headliner of the thing that they brought
in this gorgeous structure I don't know
you've seen it it looks like at the
inside of a Mac store but it's outdoors
in Austin it's like a monolithic looking
cool thing and so I made a joke
something about LGB I did all the
letters and then I said that's my record
locator on my flight and that got an
awful quiet response and I didn't
understand it because I was I'm with
them but I'm not making fun of them I'm
part of them maybe the joke just wasn't
that good I think so from your response
it's possible to you're carrying around
your head and then I did another I did a
song about transitioning that I'd
written for
the event transitioning what you know a
male to a female and me having a
relationship because I do comedy music
in the purest way cuz I love writing
songs and singing and I've always done
that in my standup I started as a
musical act that we would all ridicule
and and I had to pull before I got to
the end of it because it was just it got
quieter and I heard crickets and I felt
so bad because I was doing it as saying
hold on hold on stop stop yeah it was
killing I did it on a special but but
you're doing it at an lbgtq a positive
event that's because I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and I care about people more I care
about all human beings I don't I don't
have a racist bone in my I don't
understand anything I'm an idiot I'm a
[ __ ] what are your dicks racist my
dick is so don't thank you thank you you
saved me you know science bits it racism
but you know that that's not a comedy
look I don't do any sort of benefit and
the reason why I would just donate money
I don't do benefits because it's not my
sister scleroderma and I do but do any
money no but would you do a tape for my
by viral event in October wouldn't do
REME inutes on wouldn't do she died Joe
I wouldn't die listen to me I wouldn't
do acrobatics and a benefit to help
people with spina bifida no no we're
buying a pivot is hilarious by the way I
don't know if you've had it no are
crippled okay I'm night you know what
I'm saying like you're doing comedy in
an event where people are talking about
a serious issue that maybe they've been
maligned and misgendered and just
[ __ ] disenfranchise their whole life
and then you're on stage telling you
know a questionable joke that wasn't
your best joke and then a song about
transitioning and you wondering why
they're not laughing it's not funny to
them cuz it's not it's not a comedy show
why do Ramat you gotta think why weren't
you in my life sooner you could will you
manage me know so here's here's
here's the thing the thing that I do I'm
part of the slur demur Research
Foundation because my sister died of
this disease what is this disease it's a
hardening of the skin sclera
means hardening and derma means skin and
a lot of people have it different people
people a lot of people and
proportionately hits people of African
descent
not unlike corona virus hits the lungs
Queen Latifah's mother passed away from
it I know other people who've had it
it's it's uh and I lost my sister and my
dear friend and the first person to ever
do the benefit benefit was Robin
Williams and he did it seven times after
and we've raised fifty three million
dollars and we're curing people it's
amazing a blur what do they into
remission what did they do for the cure
like what how they there's new therapies
my sister was mistreated and guinea pig
they gave her cortisone and prednisone
which drives you [ __ ] nuts and they
just tested stuff and the the
rheumatologist that did it to her is no
longer alive and and how do you sue
somebody that didn't know what he was
doing but now their centers at Johns
Hopkins and at UCSF and Stanford and
there are really new drugs like really
great ones so it's always been a comedy
benefit and their people their patients
there and I've always had everybody's
done it Chappell did it for me in LA at
the Beverly Wilshire and I had it was it
was wonderful I mean I think was John
Mayer got up on stage and I think it was
Ray Romano and wonder if it was gothic
I've had almost every comedian do it but
Chappelle made me put on the invite and
Dave Chappelle might come says deja Paul
says he might come and he flew himself
out and he did the damn thing and he
couldn't do material because we didn't
lock up phones and he did a half hour of
being the beautiful person that he is
that's awesome and so all I was saying
was Robin did it seven [ __ ] times so
hmm
here's my question so Richard Jeni
Patrice Brodie you know all these people
Sam
if chris farley wasn't a stand-up but
wider really truly funny people have to
die shouldn't there be some kind of
universal law Mitch Hedberg Mitch hi
bill helix well you know people die bro
it's part of life I know but they but
but the love when you see Robin Williams
to somebody anybody they get emotional
you know because he he could have never
done stand-up and just acted in movies
when 9/11 happened you know about 9/11
right yeah okay
can't do that you can't do that joke
it's not a joke
it's just me being an ass thanks for
thanks for sitting through this with me
oh I knew I haven't had my shrink in a
while you go to a shrink no you smartest
[ __ ]
so anyway sensory deprivation tank oh
dear yeah that's cool yeah you get alone
with your thoughts for real I've done it
have you yeah I got one here you do yeah
it's all salt and the gunner then you
play music no two tones mankind knows
your thoughts just my thoughts I just do
breathing exercises I know that you you
know the readings of Terence Mckenna
because I was a mushroom boy good friend
to his brother it's no [ __ ] yeah his
brother Dennis is amazing
holy crap yeah yeah I was gonna see I
was I had a 420 show in Vancouver he
lives in BC now he's a expat he bailed
out of this [ __ ] wacky country and
went to it just as wacky one right [ __ ]
but I love Vancouver I mean he picked a
good spot
I love Vancouver let me just finish the
Robin thought please yeah because I
apologize
so 9/11 happens and I'm home and I'm
alone my kids I was divorced my kids
were at their moms and all the channels
are running the footage for 24 hours and
Fox television runs mrs. Doubtfire and
I'm like what a great [ __ ] thing they
did for me and for people and I know a
lot of people that I've talked to over
the years that go yeah
watch mrs. Doubtfire that night they
[ __ ] on their network which was still
kind of a new network in a way they ran
it and it's a story about divorce and
what he would do to get back to his kids
yeah and his acting in in that is you
know it's a great movie it's a sweet
movie that's a movie that I gave as an
example when someone saying I because
someone was saying that trans people are
never funny and a straight person in
drag is never funny I go you can't say
it's never funny and I said you don't
think it's it's never funny when someone
pretends to be a woman and the guy says
it's never funny I go mrs. Doubtfire
Totti well that's a good one too but
there's a lot of them mrs. Doubtfire is
a very strong example but it's not about
that's not about that it's about having
to do it the greatest disguise to be
able to see his kids yes but he's still
pretending to be a woman and it's
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah yeah yeah well he he was all I was
saying was if he had never done stand-up
if Robin had just been just been a great
actor well know what he's doing now I
mean Eddie Murphy was one of the best
stand-ups ever stops yeah and now he
just does films I have a I have a story
for you about him they think you'll dig
so I'm hosting the main room thinking
I'll never get a career everybody's off
everybody's gone Arsenio is gone
Howie what do you mean you think you
never get a career I was on the road not
making a lot of money but in the
meantime I would host for years the
Westwood store which was no more which
was fun actually Sam so you're really
young at this time then mm-hmm my 20s
you weren't gonna have a career yeah
already in your 20s yeah I was depressed
all my 20s my all of them that's great I
was I'd be on a plane and didn't care if
it went down that's how stupid I was
really I should have been gone to a
doctor that's what I should have done be
that depressed so I'm there and I'm
hosting and Eddie Murphy comes in and
this is not on the bill he didn't call
for a spot so Eddie comes in
he's working out raw and I don't know
that it's raw but then he comes out and
he's in I can't remember if it's a blue
leather or the red leather suit but he's
in one of them and he looks like a
[ __ ] god I mean he looks I've never
seen anyone more beautiful Oh what I
look at oh my god his skin was like
butter I mean I wanted to kiss him he's
still beautiful
he's he's amazing he's one of the most
but he wanted to be the Beatles of
comedy he is he is so I'm the host on a
Friday night and it was Sam's gonna go
on later and he comes out and the place
standing ovations the walls shake and he
does about 50 minutes on a Friday night
Wow and I'm watching it and it's good
and it's and I'm laughing and I'm seeing
in he's working he's working it yeah
that's why he's there and he's getting
and he's getting ready for something
because he's dressed in his wardrobe
for what will be the suit that's gonna
be the show the movie and then he
finishes and it and it great applause
standing ovation but what you would
expect I was there the next four I was
there all the time
I lived there which is why I went away
for a long time besides work happened I
was on Broadway and whatever the [ __ ]
happen just on the street you know I'm
just begging but I but a week later a
week one week later the following Friday
he comes out in the other color suit I
don't know if it was blue or red I'm
feeling it was blue that that other
Friday one Friday later and I asked had
he gone up at The Improv or laugh factor
anywhere and they said no he comes up
and he does an hour and tenth standing
ovation when it starts I watched how
great he is with my own eyes ears and
heart it was I never saw anything like
it
I've though when he was done he had
crushed it so
strong in a way that was so [ __ ] funny
cuz it was it had a motion in it and it
had talked about racism and it talked
about just fine it was dirty and it was
great and the wall literally the
building shook and that buildings got
like dead mobsters underneath it that's
very solid that building this cement
down there I'm not kidding the wall I
thought it was an earthquake I didn't it
was minutes minutes of applause and I
come back on stage you know and he's
face to face with me and I go that that
was [ __ ] amazing
and he just gave me a a nod like yes sir
and then he was gone and he was always
very kind to me too but I got to see
that I got to see in one week what
brilliance it took for him so what do
you think he did do you think he just
went and reviewed the material and if he
didn't perform it all that week he must
have so not necessarily know I think not
necessarily is the answer no I think he
just did what we do when we're good and
went over it and over it and over long
as he worked at it
there's no way you didn't work at it
well sometimes he just he didn't just
leave it there but sometimes it's not
that sometimes it's just inspiration
sometimes you feel different sometimes
you just feel better like sometimes you
go onstage just feel loose yeah he's got
an idea so and do it you feel physically
better maybe like maybe you're more well
rested or maybe he didn't like this set
the week before so he didn't thinking
about it for all that I could tell he
didn't after that first set because he
was his mind was worrying like it does
when we're trying to work it out
well listen man that's the weirdest
thing about doing a special you leave
that material to the ether it's gone and
then you start from scratch you have no
weapons so here you have these people
that come to see you oh my god it's Bob
Saget I love Bob Saget I'm so excited
and you ain't got [ __ ] for them I did
that scrambling never did that after my
look every time I do a set of the Comedy
Store after my special comes out
I don't have anything I have a few
scraps I have a few ideas how a few
premises you know this last time I got
lucky that I had a couple that I
couldn't really do my last special and I
never really fleshed out I could start
with them I could kind of get going get
get a little bit of momentum and then
piece together an act but that
desperation is what creates your your
act
that's this last after that happened and
what I could feel what was happening in
the world the past and you could too
for the past year year and a half of
what was what we were going toward with
Trump at the helm and all of the [ __ ]
that's been happening and all the people
at each other so I it started happening
fast where new stuff was coming to me
and I was reflective over my life and
and reflective over real things more
real things not just a bunch of nonsense
or just so you wanted to do more real
thoughtful story-tell things that mean
something to you rather than just jokes
but I'd but I can't help myself as you
could apparently tell without taking
little asides to throw in something
that's just like [ __ ] what would you
say that you want to do this dork how
much time were you working how much are
you doing quite a bit I've been on the
road and I've been wanting to be on the
road more than I've ever wanted to be on
the road Wow that so up until pandemic I
was set to go to Canada and they closed
Canada the day before actually they
closed that the day after I pulled on
Vancouver and they were basically just
touring back and forth and just doing a
lot a lot of clubs getting everything a
lot of clubs that fit a theater a bunch
of theater runs little theater runs now
it's not big ones line everything nice
and loose yeah and when we think about
filming I was gonna go fall this year me
too I was already I know where I'm gonna
shoot it I don't even want to say
because I have some views cool [ __ ] that
I have that I want to do that it's part
of the place if part of it but it's just
then I can't look like it's bad I can't
feel like it's just gonna what we're all
going through is just gonna make me
mene mene even more everything we're
gonna get to do when there's a vaccine
when we find out if their vaccine works
fine huh what the [ __ ] all this is when
we get to go out and really do a room
that's a hundred percent full and we
don't know it you don't know it's coming
with your big dates coming up I don't
think they're all getting canceled if I
had a guess I mean unless something
happens between I mean I'm supposed to
Madison Square Garden October
have you played there before yeah I've
played the smaller room but I'm doing
the big room in Boston Garden
back-to-back two weeks in a row other
[ __ ] and I don't know if that's
happening Chappell and I have a bunch of
gigs so I don't know if that's happening
but you'll just move them you'll just
move them a year right yes a year a
year's likely but even then we don't
what kind of a climate are we looking at
what is the world gonna be like that's
the least of my concern right now I mean
doing stand-up is great I would I would
like to do stand-up again right what's a
selfish cancel right right now I just
wanna look if we'd never do stand-up
again man life is beautiful I want to
appreciate life when I appreciate my
friends I want appreciate my family I
appreciate being able to do this podcast
this has been one of the nicest things
that there's a place that I could sit
and hang out with people and talk and
learn like our this podcast has made me
grow a lot as a human being it has a lot
I've well I've listened and watched it's
uh it's shifted my perspective it's made
me way more aware of how much
responsibility I have doing this thing
when we first started doing this podcast
it was you know me and Brian Redman and
you know whoever the guest was Joey Diaz
or Eddie Bravo or Ari Shaffir or
whatever it was and it would be like a
thousand people listening at the most
you know again like a thousand downloads
would be crazy and so we got to practice
when there was like no stakes and you
could still listen to them and some of
them are terrible and some of them are
getting me in trouble now because some
of the ridiculous [ __ ] we said right
trying to make each other's laugh but
that led to this and did you for
whatever reason we just kept doing it or
I just kept doing it it became this did
you have any vision in your mind that it
would be what other people
look at as like an empire no [ __ ]
chance no he just did it just did it I'm
a grinder I'm a person that I see
something and I try to get better at it
and I know that I had a bunch of podcast
that weren't that good and so I go what
was wrong with that one well I talk too
much
or maybe I interrupted too much or maybe
I didn't have enough to say about the
subject so maybe I should be more
prepared maybe I should write be more
focused and then I really what what is
what's a distraction like make sure
people don't look at their phones make
sure you're locked in be really engaged
be in the moment in the conversation be
better at that and I just kept doing it
that's kind of you're an influence on me
in a huge regard because I didn't come
to podcast because every [ __ ] person
on the earth saw the kid across the
street has a podcast you know might
think IUP s guy the other day had a
podcast really no but it's okay but I
I'm like on number 33 and I'm I'm
learning very fast cuz I'm a broadcaster
you know I had I know how to do things
but it's not it's it's a conversation
that's why I'm so drawn to what you do
it's people listening this is the most
thing and it's and if they love it and
they and they need it but it's also you
have to listen to the way you sound you
have to listen to the way the
conversations going like it has to be
there has to be something in what you're
talking about and the way you're talking
that makes people want to listen I don't
know how to teach that I know I mean I
don't know I think but you get better at
it it's a skill there's something to it
that's just like everything else man
it's like I don't play the piano but I
would imagine it's like playing the
piano or learning any other skill the
more time and focus you put into it the
better you get at it and it's to me it's
it's fascinating still to this day if I
get a scientist in here or a researcher
or someone who's writing a book on
something Elon Musk with a flamethrower
yeah it's fascinating I having those
conversations I'm I'm locked in man I
love it I enjoy it and I never never
thought I'd be doing this and this is
not a plan
there was no plan - this isn't that the
best it's great I don't know if it's the
best
but it's great well it's the best
i-i think it's the best because it comes
from an organic place and that's why it
worked that's why it works I mean that's
why it's got even I don't know if you
read but you're you're you're you're
moving it I don't know if you're read
about it yeah that's right here some
people that work for me to tell me that
yeah that's moving somewhere I can't
remember where but I just moved it
somewhere big apparently yeah I you know
and that's it that's what mine [ __ ] too
because now it's like there's more
scrutiny on it there's more people
paying attention and criticism and
everything but it's also it's like I
just keep doing it I just keep going and
I just keep focusing on that and that's
the real challenge right as it gets
bigger can you keep doing it the way
you're doing it can you keep getting
high and get drunk and have friends here
and just talk [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna see
until the wheels fall off
kkeok they're not gonna fall off because
you're a special guy I'm just telling
you I'm 64 I could say [ __ ] like that
what if when you're 62 did not let you
know I wasn't allowed
I was talking to Norman Lear the other
night it's gonna be 98 how's he doing
he's [ __ ] genius on the ball at night
we were we had a zoom with a bunch of
music guys like I said and he is one of
the most beautiful people I've ever I
will ever know which is born into being
sharpened 90 airs about humanity he you
know he changed television he gave us
all in the family and Sanford and Son
and of good times in the Jeffersons
isn't it crazy that none of those shows
you could do today but they're doing
them they are doing the live ones on ABC
Jimmy Kimmel in here doing those what
all the family and these ever since have
been running up new episodes
what did Woody Harrelson's archie bunker
shot erisa to may is Edith shut the [ __ ]
out sorry you really need to Google this
is this actually happens Janek a couple
months ago what yes
before the pandemic what this is about
as real as it gets
how the [ __ ] am I just hearing this how
can you I told you something you need
him out this is woody harrelson woody
and they sing those were the days bunker
and yes the [ __ ] out and it's [ __ ]
awesome Joe it's awesome
and norman lear and there's Marisa this
is crazy you have to watch it it's a
costume this is real no it's it's how do
you joking
no I didn't know about this well I gave
you
I gave Joe Intel live in front of a
studio audience all in the family hole
so it's Norman and Kimmel and ABC and
it's [ __ ] one of the producers yeah
they do it together and it's it's
[ __ ] oh it's so special because the
stuff is about racism because people
didn't quite understand some people were
just loving Archie and not getting the
sadness dressed like they're in the 70s
yeah so it takes place in this jesse
eisenberg dollars yes and I like on The
Jeffersons yeah Jamie Foxx I mean this
is yes this is big [ __ ] gotta go and
watch it
you've got to look it up you got to
watch a little bit that old man that
doesn't know anything anymore
I'm completely out of the loop I'm so
relevant you're the relevant as
government no the most relevant is
Norman Lear
so he's 98 look at this this is crazy
it's absolutely was gonna do Sanford and
Son I don't know if they're gonna do
that why not I don't know if you can do
Redd Foxx
Cle ugly good there's a few people I
love dl 92 I think he could do it so he
was on stage and saying he's in
Nashville and he passes out and he's got
coronavirus I know how good is his tour
manager that caught him as he was
falling asleep yeah I'm not amazing
could have had his head crowd oh for
sure he was going down you know what I'm
sure this is what I was saying about all
these comedians that we love and I got
I'm so fed up with that cuz i I'll of
comedian so much I started I don't reach
out to DL that often but we see each
other once in a while I started texting
were you okay it's Bob Saget please
don't think I'm weird I can't [ __ ]
take I can't [ __ ] take it anymore you
please don't think I'm weird and then
Mary text me back he's laughing he's
good I'm okay I said well I wrote
something else I'm sorry I texted you
then the next day I called him I said
what the [ __ ] man
how sick are you because I'm okay I'm
okay
he doesn't seem to be that sick I saw
him talking no it seems okay bit of a
cough
you know Bryan Callen got it yeah and
he's fine now he was wrong mechanism his
instruments pretty together
well he didn't take any medication
Brendan Schaub his friend took
medication and he was fun for days
encounter took him like 11 or 12 but
he's fine now he said it feels good I'm
concerned with long-term effects from
anybody that has this because I was
talking to a friend of mine who is a
doctor who's saying he's treating a
basketball player who three months and a
guy in his 20s three months after kovat
is still having issues with his
endurance he hasn't gotten his endurance
back to where it is like his his lungs
are not working at full capacity so
there's perhaps some damage or something
saying for people their scarring yeah
that happens [ __ ] terrifying you know
what is this Jamie scans reveal heart
damage and over half of kovat 19
patients and study oh great
maybe they should go with more patients
there was something else I could send
this to you
there was another well it's not
necessary but it was essentially saying
that in the autopsies that they're doing
on people who died of kovat they're
finding blood clots and all of their
organs and their liver their lungs or
kidneys everywhere yeah this is a
[ __ ] weird disease man and they don't
know if the vac and what I've been
hearing with the vaccine they don't know
if you get it if it doesn't if it can
keep you safe they don't know no no but
they don't know first of all they don't
know if a vaccine is gonna be even
possible normally it takes a vaccine
upwards of four years to develop and
they're trying to do this in fast-track
it and they're also trying to do
something called an mRNA vaccine it's a
different kind of vaccine that doesn't
use a live version of the virus but
instead forces your body to create
proteins I don't see if we could pull up
what that means
MRR like remember I'm a [ __ ] so when I
say these things even though I use the
right words I really don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm saying very important are you
becoming me mRNA virus so you begin em
excuse me mRNA vaccine
but it's not saying what it like that's
it with a profession of mRNA vaccine
messenger RNA messenger RNA see it does
something to the body and forces the
body to create proteins that fight off
the virus another thing that's really
important is vitamin D they are fighting
and this is what you were talking about
with African Americans having a
particular problem with kovat African
Americans have a particular problem with
vitamin D as well because of course with
their skin color their ancestors all
came from Africa where your body had all
this melanin to protect itself from
constant sunlight so they didn't have to
worry about absorbing so much vitamin D
from the Sun they were in the Sun all
the time this is the reason why Irish
people are so [ __ ] pale the reason
why they're so [ __ ] pale is because
where they are there's no goddamn Sun so
their body has to be like a solar panel
for vitamin D your body produces vitamin
D because of sunlight and it's not just
a vitamin sits it's actually a hormone
which is I'm really busy getting into
this lately do you take a lot of
supplements vitamin D yes my wife's a
thousand IU's a day so I was talking to
your guys before I came in here and they
were saying yes she got it I've been out
in the sunlight cuz I've been out go to
the pool that's like Hawaii for my wife
and I and she's you know that's been
helpful it feels good that's good but
you're also getting a little bit of sun
damage there too right you got to be
careful about that yeah I put on the
[ __ ] but is that protecting you from
vitamin D as well probably what you
should do is get blood work done and
find out where your vitamin levels are
it's not hard to do go to a good doctor
they can do blood work my wife wanted me
to take supplements she says she as
right before I came in here she said
that's what I've been trying you don't
take vitamins she said I do I do but I
don't take too many vitamins you should
go to a doctor that really understands
this kind of [ __ ] and could look at your
blood work and say hey you need niacin
you need vitamin D you're low in zinc
and all those things protect you is it a
normal doctor or is it a person that'll
talk afterwards
yeah you have a body that is deficient
in nutrients that body lacks the the
strength to prevent illnesses it's the
the part of what your immune system is
is your your body has a an army that
fights off bad diseases
right and when your body doesn't have
any building blocks your body doesn't
have any nutrients your body is is
deficient and all sorts of critical
nutrients that it needs for all these
different functions it's not gonna do
the job it's real simple when your
body's weak it's not gonna do the job
but fortunately for us in 2020 you can
take supplements and vitamin D is not
expensive it's not prohibitive but it
has a huge impact one of the things that
they're showing is that and this is
something that dr. Rhonda Patrick talked
about when she was on the podcast
she went over all these different
studies that they've done in places
where kovat patients were in the ICU and
in one of them and it's several but one
of them that can recall 80 plus percent
of the people that were in the ICU for
four kovat had vitamin D deficiency four
percent had sufficient levels of vitamin
D and there's multiple studies that
point to the exact same thing is that
this is it's critical in your body's
ability to fight off illness and
particularly effective with kovat so
when you're talking about African
Americans one of the things my doctor
told me was that when he was doing tests
in Manhattan with African Americans some
of them had non detectable levels of
vitamin D so these are people that first
of all their ancestors come from a
climate where they're supposed to be in
the Sun all the time now they're not
because they're in this northern
hemisphere cloudy they're it's in the
winter they're not getting anything on
the Sun and they're not taking any
vitamins so they're just not getting it
it makes them particularly susceptible
another thing that makes people
particularly susceptible is obesity that
that is according to my friend who's a
doctor in New York is a huge factor in
people that are in the I see that quite
a bit
obesity is a huge factor obesity vitamin
D those are two big ones zinc zinc does
something that stops the the virus's
ability to get into the body I don't
know how that works but something about
your body's the the virus's ability to
enter into the body is somehow or
another stop by zinc I've always had a
problem taking too many supplements I
went on a lot of kicks I had doctor a
couple doctors recommend certain
vitamins and D was one of them for sure
and biotin and he's [ __ ] huge man
most people
it upset your stomach cuz like see
upsets my stomach I don't know I has an
acidic stomach it just what I'm talking
about
it feels like it's burning a hole
through it when I take a vitamin C well
you take it with food that's what I've
done wrong right where's well fart it's
like a white cloud a white cloud yeah
you look like mere white far how do you
know it's who doesn't I mean you never
looked over and farted in them here
over the shoulder I don't think I have
maybe we should do a photo session maybe
not let's say not and not we didn't you
should take vitamins with food most
vitamins are they get to take them
better for or after well I think the
best way to do is probably the middle of
your meal like eat when you're when
you're eating violence which I've seen a
lot of photos yeah a lot of elk pictures
would you take the D in the middle of
four pieces of them do you take them yes
I have a hard time telling people to do
what I do and basically everything cuz
they're not only my name cuz you're kind
of like perfect humans but they're not
gonna do it they're not gonna do what I
do physically they're not I might take
advice I have a stack of vitamins it's
like it's like this like a [ __ ]
Monopoly board and I pull those bad boys
out when I eat and I pour four of these
and two of those and ten of those and I
just eat those and I eat them with my
food that's what I do when I'm eating
I'll stop in the middle of the meal and
I go out and I get my box and I have a
box let me ask you a question right
fish oil right yeah what does it do it
is probably not a good topic but what
does it do to your stool what happens I
don't know I always do it you have a
nice one is it regular [ __ ] alright is
it tapered like a [ __ ] hammer bro
comes out hard residual or no it's a
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay so it's not in
compartments it doesn't come out all
separate like vitamins no you don't like
[ __ ] like forty vitals no [ __ ] cat has
anything to do with your [ __ ]
it's uh would you know just your [ __ ]
comes from food waste
that's what [ __ ] is yeah I didn't know
that it's mostly fiber for a lot of
people when you eat meat only that's
what's interesting
yeah you were on that
you lost a bunch of weight on that yeah
I did when I did that I had smaller
shit's it was interesting I was like I
was eating a lot of meat but like your
absorbs it and you know it's meat is
mostly water right so you've got like
the the the tissue and then the water
and the amount that your [ __ ] is
surprisingly small whereas when you're
eating a lot of salad and you're eating
a lot of likes raillery and fibrous
foods all that stuff your body doesn't
really digest it but it's just for you
right I don't know I don't really saying
that we need to have our vegetables
around everybody some people are saying
you need to have the vegetables and then
there's some people that are on this
carnivore diet that say you don't need
any vegetables some people are vegan
like my wife's a pescetarian she
worships fish and I am on I'm be
positive blood so I'm your old goes is a
humanitarian someone who eats people
I've I mean that's gonna happen soon I
think we're already happened we're on
the but I mean I think this could become
popular you think so yeah I think on
what if lab created human meat is the
best thing to eat at a restaurant it's
like the veal we have some beautiful lab
created human created Botox you can get
it mommy
they would have that Mommy has people a
restaurant they come out and they have
learning those like [ __ ] Bugs Bunny
silver things when they pull the top off
of it and it's a dude's but it's just a
perfect but like out like a athlete hey
the best ass today and he's like this
we're gonna crock-pot this it's gonna be
a beautiful beautiful roast for you and
it's not it doesn't not a part of an
actual person it was all created in a
lab right so someone who's always wanted
to eat you guys ass simulated I mean who
doesn't pull that top off hunt and show
them simulated man ass like if you go to
Morton's they combine with this the
steak tray yeah and they show you this
is the ribeye beautiful I mean they're
making lab-created meat why not make lab
created human meat you eat that stuff
I have never because it's not available
but I would try it but not man
oh that fake [ __ ] ya know the soybeans
just terrible my wife gives it to me I
don't really love it it's supposed to
taste pretty good but it's not good for
you it's not good for she made
vegetarian or vegan eat vegetables eat
actual real vegetables don't eat some
fake beef [ __ ] that's not real food
I need my meat I eat meat then yeah I go
but it's not supposed to be good for
your heart to what people but if you
looked into that No
yeah see that's the thing that people
just keep saying yeah they hear what so
you know man sugar sugar and an in fact
fine flour no that's not bad for you
that's essential you need fat it's
actually I thought so I thought it's
also good it helps lube up the meat so
you can [ __ ] better perhaps listen we
can go down this rabbit hole but it's
already four o'clock it would take a
long time from it's for depression to
you yes [ __ ] I'm flies in this
room your your enchanted [ __ ] do you do
this you say you talk yeah you have a
good time a couple hours passed by Papa
I love this was fun glad we did it but I
love it tell people about your podcast
how they get it it's on you know it's
wherever you get them right it's
everybody Adam Apple it's a Spotify is
it on zig zag is it on YouTube as well
or it is I but I got a brand new YouTube
site I'm a newbie so I just it's up
there for zoom videos because I've been
talking to people beautiful but I have
really good guests I've been having that
but I call people to to see how they're
doing and Instagram just Bob Saget yeah
I Instagram Twitter
I got tick-tock until China pulls it
don't don't get off the tick-tock
therefore they're watching you ever move
are they really the Chinese government
during your ass right now maybe I need
that maybe you do but what about what
about you know Alexa isn't she listening
to every listen everything everything so
was the show she the Apple home don't
mother [ __ ] listen series series
[ __ ] today yes yes knows everything
all of them [ __ ]
her yes she and Alexis should take a
slow boat to [ __ ] pill there you go
let's end with that Pop's I gotta love
you I love you James buddy thank you a
lot of fun this is great goodbye America
and the rest of the world see ya